foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
indicatement day
that was the best birthday gift ever
yesterday
you Alvin Bragg for the great birth
again I appreciate it
I'm listening yesterday it was my
birthday that had to have been what
happened
oh my [__] god well here we are we're
at the first indictment day this is the
first
of indictments that will come down
apparently there's 34 business fraud
charges oh [__]
uh I've been saying for a while now I
don't know if you've been listening or
not but the uh the hush money payment
that they keep yelling screaming about
that's that's probably not what he's
getting indicted for
that just that just shut off the
investigation
and I think it was Mueller she wrote is
the one who pointed out this morning
that the Mueller investigation actually
um is the snowball here that is the
investigation that found
the payment to Stormy Daniels in the
Michael Cohen case in the first place
so
this idea that uh the investigations
that were into Trump over and over and
over again and ah there there's nothing
from those
this is it this is what you get from
those you get 17 counts of fraud on the
Trump organization
tried and convicted and now we have what
seems like this is the leak right this
is what we know
is supposedly there's going to be 34
business fraud charges now that doesn't
mean that there could be that there's
only 34 charges there could be more
charges I mean let's say there's just 34
business fraud charges just just just
that and then there's other charges on
top of that who knows I mean this
morning
um grandpa poopy pants is absolutely
having a shitty diaper fit on fraud
social
where he seems to be threatening the
judge
seems to be you know
uh Donald Trump has a lot of ideas about
legal strategy
um but trying to make sure that he
doesn't have a gag order
it seems like that political strategy
isn't going to work out very well
because that's that's really the next
step right and so the next step is for
these charges to be unsealed they are
sealed we don't know what they are yet
so when manga says oh there it's all
[__] it's all [__] well how the
[__] you know what's all [__] you
know you know what the 34 the three four
counts they saying or business right you
don't even know what they're pertaining
to
you have no [__] clue dummy and
and we will see these uh charges
unsealed
I might I don't know exactly
um New York's unsealing process I know
uh this morning Albert and Bragg has
even had the word Jim Jordan and Jim
Comer uh the Chairman's the chairman of
the uh oversight committee
chairman of the Judiciary Committee that
hey [__] you better back off
you better not be obstructing
if you're using your
capacity to abstract we will strike
I mean if Donald Trump is coordinating
with Jim Jordan Jim Comer in here to use
the government to web weaponize the
government
against a duly elected local prosecutor
for convenia grand jury grand jury
voting to indicts one a private citizen
who committed crimes within their
jurisdiction and you're weaponizing the
government you son of a [__]
so we'll see
we'll see how it's going this morning
the audio something about the audio is
my audio bed hang on
now how is it
is it getting better here let me back up
maybe maybe not
people are saying the audio is bad
audio is screwing up
course
of course on indictment day this seems
like the Deep State at play here seems
much better now is it okay is it better
now it's better okay okay I just uh I
just adjusted my mic a bit
oh boy
yeah hell must be the Deep state must be
it's this must be a woke mic that's
probably what it is the mic is woke
don't worry folks
oh boy
[Laughter]
is it better now
that fixed it they said that fixed it
audio is much better now okay good I
just turned the mic off and turned it
back on is all I did
oh my God so uh what was I took oh yes
Jim Jordan and Jim Comer committing
obstructing committing obstruction
obstruction of justice I must still be
hanging over from the bottle of Jaeger
that I drank the other night
um
so Jim Jordan
Jim Comer
[Music]
honestly I could see the situation where
the uh former president United States
has ordered
Jim Jim and Jimbo
to obstruct Justice here and use their
power Uh Kevin McCarthy made a statement
without knowing the charges as well or
so did Ron DeSantis did you see this
Rhonda santis is done I listen I thought
maybe his window opened back up
um for you know
when when Grandpa poopy pants went to
his rally with the wackos in Waco and he
didn't really attack Ron DeSantis like I
thought he would I thought Ron
desantis's window to run open back up
but yesterday Ron DeSantis closed it all
the way himself saying I will not I will
not participate in any kind of
extradition [__] out of here you are not
gonna have to extract this sumbitch
he had Secret Service detail
ticket service detailed normally
especially with someone and trying to
protect someone like Donald Trump kind
of kind of dictates a little bit of his
movements
um so we'll we'll see exactly how they
surrender him what do you think do you
think he's going to be in a pair of
handcuffs or not and people you know
that's the one thing everyone wants they
want the booking photo
he's gonna be fingerprint he's gonna be
processed just like any other [__]
criminal defendant in the Manhattan DA's
office
I mean in the courthouse excuse me as
the Manhattan D.A brings their charges
but do you do you think
do you think he'll be in a pair of hand
because I actually don't believe he'll
go in a hand kiss this these aren't
violent crimes
um he's gonna self-surrender he's gonna
have he's gonna have an escort from a
law enforcement officer anyways in the
Secret Service whether it's one or two
or three of these guys I don't think
he's gonna actually get in a pair of
handcuffs and honestly I I doubt we'll
even get much of a of a shot of him
coming from his SUV into the courthouse
maybe we will maybe we won't now what I
will I will tell you that I want is for
him to come out afterwards in front of
the courthouse and do one of these
[__] uh Courthouse things where he's
speaking into a microphone oh my God
please inject that into my [__] veins
I'm serious the more this guy talks the
worse it's gonna get for him the more he
posts on true social the worse it's
gonna get for him these are not itbd
charges folks
you've been hearing this a lot from even
people on the left they're like oh I
can't believe they're even doing this
these are such small charges there's 34
counts of business fraud
at a minimum I guess
right
I mean that's what we know we don't know
what the actual business fraud is we
have no idea at this point we know that
he that Trump organization was found
guilty of 17 counts of fraud
the organization that he's ran for
decades
and his CFO Alan weisenberg is sitting
in Rikers right now
maybe maybe just maybe weitzelberg is
making deals
to get 34 counts of criminal fraud on
Donald Trump who the [__] knows at this
point and for anyone it anyone out there
especially any of these megalodites oh
Fox News did you watch this last night
Lindsey Graham was [__] crying
Jesse Waters had tears rolling out of
his eyes what a bunch of goddamn [__]
ass [__] are you kidding me you
weren't prepared for Donald Trump to be
indicted are you [__] [__] me you
people have had two goddamn years two
[__] years to prepare
yourselves for Donald Trump's
indictments
give me a [__] break and you're
surprised by this Lindsey Graham just
absolutely losing his goddamn [__] on
air
begging begging for Donald Trump
supporters to give him money because
that's exactly what a billionaire needs
right a real billionaire needs more
money
like Elon Musk needs [__] blue check
subscribers
turd sandwiches you people worship the
dumbest [__] you know that
moglodytes these Maga idiots oh my God
these [__] these white trumped up
dudes that you worship the dumbest
stupidest sons of [__] you know that
you people really are [__] stupid oh
my God
and you're supposed to be the master
race good Lord
Jesus Christ and you can't even figure
out which one of these Knuckleheads is
the smartest of them the [__] out of
here man oh
I I'm just happy today I am I'm happy
I'm happy and that they're gonna have
one of these spaces later on today I'm
not sure exactly who's all going to be
there I hope Jenna Ellis is there again
I love I'd love to to hand it to Jenna
Ellis if Jenna Ellis is in there I'm
gonna [__] eat her lunch and that uh
said Gorka hopefully he shows up Tom
Vinton uh I hope he comes in and shows
up I I really I really I was listening
last night a little bit as they were
wrapping up uh Joe Walsh came in the
space and was uh firing off a few of
these things but then they got into the
whole Russia Russia Russia thing and
they they give you enough [__] weeds
look
look it's really simple this guy is a
[__] criminal okay we all know he's a
criminal he's been a criminal for a long
time it's not [__] news
it really shouldn't even news that this
guy is is [__] indicted okay it
really is not that big a news it isn't
the only reason why it's news is because
he still has a cult following
I mean imagine imagine a world where
where they abandoned his ass they
[__] impeached him
they [__] impeached him when they
should have impeached him removed him
from office and now he would be indicted
on 34 counts of business fraud man it
wouldn't be [__] news it would be
like yeah no [__] [__] put that
son of a [__] in jail [__] him that's
what it should be like but it's not
because he still has a cult they're
still worshiping at the altar of trump
because they love white supremacy that's
what they love and they're terrified
terrified of diversity equity and
inclusion I mean it's like the the
[__] Grand enemy here
it's really stupid [__]
but this is what fascists do
they idolize dumb [__] like
Donald Trump they idolize dumb
[__] like Ron DeSantis Jim
Jordan Marjorie Taylor green Lauren
bobert Matt gatz Elon Musk
fascism is stupid ass [__] it's a dumb
ideology it doesn't make any sense
especially in 2023 it just doesn't and
most people aren't gonna buy that [__]
but a few [__] about 10 12 of
the country
and it's all a fraud anyways that
somehow he has big support you are you
people thinking that he's gonna win the
president here's their argument they're
like oh my God this is going to destroy
our country and it's only going to
guarantee that Donald Trump becomes
president so which is it or is it both
is it going to destroy our country
because Donald Trump is guaranteed the
presidency
or is he is he going to be president and
then destroy the country or is it going
to destroy it and then he's going to
make it great again or some [__] what
the [__] are you talking about
it's like they don't even look in the
mirror to repeat back their [__]
arguments that they got before they go
out in the world and spew this [__]
everywhere
it doesn't make any sense
no it's 12 percent Brandon says more
like 45 no it's 12 it's 12 percent
that's where you're at with the cult
I mean I mean he's gonna get more votes
than 12 but I'm talking about the die
hards and the die hards the delusional
[__] you know the Q and honors
and that 12's a lot that's a lot of
[__] man that's a that's that's
millions of people who are in this
[__] delusion that somehow he's the
[__] Republican Jesus or some [__]
that somehow this country is going to be
worse off because we prosecuted the most
criminal crooked [__] president of
all time
get the [__] out of here these crimes
have nothing to do with his presidency
they have to do with his business
before he was president of the United
States and while he was the president
United States you know what would be
better on Donald Trump if that
[__] would have would have let
go of his businesses when he became the
president because if any of this crime
any of this [__] crime happened and
he knew it was happening while he was
President United States which is likely
because of the statutes and limitations
if he would have just [__] let go of
his business divested in his [__]
business and walked away from it and
served as the president United States
and didn't pretend to be the [__]
president
when what he was trying to do was fleece
America with their [__] money and his
[__] businesses his [__] hotels
and his foreign governments giving him
[__] money
and apparently committing business fraud
time and time and time again then that
[__] wouldn't be in this
situation if the [__] wouldn't
have stole documents from our goddamn
government he wouldn't be in that
situation if the stupid son of a [__]
would have just admitted that yes I
[__] lost and I concede I'm gonna run
again in 2024. if he would have just
done that and walked away and not tried
to [__] commit a coup and overturn
our election
none of it he would not be in these
investigations folks this is not our
doing this is not Democrats doing this
isn't George Soros blood-sucking cabal
doing this is Donald Trump's doing
he did this
this is of his own fault no one else
no one's coming after you it's not a
[__] Witch Hunt dude
the grand jury voted based on the
evidence that the [__] Manhattan D.A
presented to him and yes can a D.A
indict a ham sandwich yeah and they
indicted one of the dumbest [__] ham
sandwiches that is ever [__] walked
in this [__] country and been a been
a leader of this country yeah they did
yesterday they [__] indicted the
dumbest ham sandwich they possibly could
[__] indict
you stupid [__]
and I can't wait to get in this space
today and go off on these [__]
I can't wait I I hope there's some
um there's some uncredible names in
there like I said Janelle's maybe Rudy
Giuliani will show up again [__] yeah
let's do it I would love to give Rudy
Giuliani a piece of my [__] mind I
definitely want to give Jenna Ellis a
piece of my [__] mind
they're not gonna like it they're
probably gonna kick me out of the room
but I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__]
because I'm tired of their [__] lies
it's enough of this stuff
it's enough this [__] that they're
spreading around
because we're about to get some of the
truth
we're about to but I want to warn you
because I know you're excited I know
it's I know it's a happy happy day right
but you're gonna have bad news right as
this goes along because a lot of people
want is going to want this to go to
trial immediately
and unfortunately it's not going to go
to trial immediately he's going to file
several motions in court to dismiss
when he finally ticks through all the
Motions to dismiss and they get turned
down and shot down and thrown in the
garbage then what he will do is he will
try a change of venue and they'll try
and try and try and try and try a change
of venue it won't work it gets tossed in
the trash just just like just like they
did with the [__] Trump organization
where they were found guilty on 17
counts of fraud
now
eventually he's going to be in a primary
race
and what I mean by that is he is going
to get on ballots
in States
and yes he is going to be in a full
election swing he's not in an election
season now this this [__] nonsense
about how he's in the election is all
[__] now
it's it's ridiculous
as if he could go rob a [__] bank and
then say hey I'm running for president
you can't indict me or or [__] you
can't go through the the normal legal
process of any other private citizen
because I said I'm running for president
get the [__] out of here that's the
dumbest [__] argument honest honestly
honestly every [__] person who
announces that they're running for
president maybe they should be
investigated at this point I'm not
saying it's a bad idea Jesus Christ
but I'm telling you what you're going to
be I'm telling you what you're going to
uh be disappointed in you're going to be
disappointed because we're not going to
have a trial of Donald Trump
the person
until after 2024. probably into 2025.
that's realistic more than likely he's
got enough money he's got enough people
who will [__] obstruct for him as in
obstructing and delaying in court not
actual obstruction just you know legal
obstruction
and trying to kick this can down the
road and kick this can down the road
because what a judge is not going to do
is have a a criminal trial during an
election because I will hand it to the
moglodytes
I will hand it to him this is going to
deliver him the nomination
and I want that
I I think that is the best thing that
this country can do think about this for
a second because the jury that actually
matters here the jury that matters
In This Moment In This timeline in our
history right now is us
the voters
we are the jury that matters
[__] the jury that that's going to be
convened for the for the charges that
they're going to put on him next week
that they're going to rein him for next
week [__] the jury that Jack Smith will
will have to convene
and the courts will have to convene for
the federal case against him in the
documents in January 6. the hell with
the jury down in Georgia that it will be
convened on whatever criminal charges
are done down there
and even if they get into the sdny about
some of the other Financial crimes that
he's done federally whether it's the
truth social Trump media thing or else
or otherwise
we are the real [__] jury here okay
we the people get to [__] decide next
year
and we don't get to decide just on Trump
because he's going to be their nominee
I mean barring something you know some
kind of Big Mac accident or something
right
I don't know he's gonna have to learn
how to keister Big Macs that's going to
be tough but I mean you know a lot of
[__] can go wrong when you're trying to
keast Your Big Macs I'm just saying
oh [__] or if this guy is stress eating
right he could choke on one of these
some [__] I'm just just saying
there's a lot of scenarios that can
happen that could change the outcome
here but more than likely modular
Knights are right he is going to be
their nominee there's not going to be
anyone else that's going to run what the
[__] is Rhonda Santa's gonna stay on say
on stage next to the sun [__] well
don't don't vote for him vote for me
I'll be a bigger criminal than he is
right what I'll I'll make sure to have
more criminal charges than this guy I
mean what the [__] is he gonna say what
the [__] is the argument huh
so yes he's gonna be your nominee I get
it great fine let's do that
because here's the thing
when we get into the 2024 general
election
and we actually get to go to The Ballot
Box
and we get to show these [__]
how much we hate this sumb [__]
how much this country hates that
[__] because in 2020 Joe Biden
didn't didn't win with 81 million votes
he didn't Joe Biden didn't get 81
million votes
the majority of those votes were against
Trump
they weren't forbiden they were against
and that's what that's what these
[__] moglodytes just don't understand
that we the people are the [__] jury
man it's us
and we're gonna slam dunk this piece of
garbage in the [__] trash
it's gonna happen
and to think that this is going to make
him Ascent to the presidency this is as
bad as delusional as this guy isn't a
criminal he's not a criminal it's just a
Witch Hunt yeah you're okay all right
whoosh all right Karen Jesus Christ
hell man
what a great day today and today's
Friday so we have bonehead of the week
in the second hour my co-host
Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining us
well we have a guest today also going to
talk about The Tick Tock band for a
little bit we haven't been able to talk
about that but we got a guest on they
talk about Tick Tock man
so stay tuned for that also if you're
listen if you're a new listener here
rather you like the hate watch or you
just like watching a show rather you
love me or you love to hate me make sure
you're subscribed either way it's free
[__] so subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast on YouTube also
go follow us on Twitter you're not gonna
be able to see us after today because we
don't have the blue check nor am I going
to buy a blue chick so follow us at Tony
Michael's pod over there we're not going
to be able to do the bonehead poll and
then that was the last bonehead poll now
we can put up polls but most of our
supporters aren't dumb [__] who
have who bought blue checks
so they they're just they're not they're
not going to be able to vote apparently
I don't know how long this new uh
Twitter thing is going to last after
tomorrow actually it might be an April's
Fool's joke to be quite honest with you
because this morning variety was
announcing that
the the thousand dollars a month you
have to pay for a blue check for an
organization oh the the biggest 10 000
accounts aren't gonna have to pay for it
so it's the small accounts that can't
afford it are the ones that are gonna
have to pay what a dumb [__] and
you it ain't no wonder you people
worship Donald Trump and Elon Musk now I
get it right like if you're gonna just
go in all in on stupid then you might as
well
[__] cash it in I guess download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google every single day we get done
recording and I edit it I throw it up on
all the directories for you to download
you should go download it every single
day it helps us out over there follow us
on Facebook if you still have a Facebook
account at the Tony Michaels you can
also subscribe to the up wire we
broadcast over on their Channel That's
the upwire.com or just search the up
wire on YouTube and subscribe there did
you know that I you can give me
a Billionaire's money and it doesn't
cost you a thing you can do it if you
have an Amazon Prime account you can
actually link it to a Twitch account
and you get one free subscription over
on Twitch with your Amazon Prime account
it's because Amazon owns twitch that's
what it is Amazon owns twitch so when
you have an Amazon Prime account you get
one free subscription
over on Twitch and you can actually give
us that subscription the Tony Michaels
podcast and we get a couple bucks of
Jeff bezos's money so go and and if you
do do that uh make sure you're you're
renewing the subscription because it's
uh every
month you have to go over there on
Twitch and renew it I think unless you
pay yearly for your Prime account I'm
not really sure I don't know how it
works just link your Prime account to
your Twitch account and give us that one
free subscription we've got almost 100
over there and I also want to thank you
for getting over 200 on the patreon
patreon page we're gonna do a ask me
anything I think I'm gonna do it the
this afternoon or later this evening
it's an ask me anything it's kind of
like shoot the [__] but it's more
private there's fewer people and I get
try to get to every single one of the
questions I don't skip questions like I
do here on shoot the [__] so go to
patreon.com D Tony Michaels or go to the
tonymichaels.com and click the patreon
link there on the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com and I want
to thank you for getting us to 200 our
goal is 250. we're getting there I think
we're 202 or something like that two or
two two or three I think it's where
we're at
so go check out patreon.com see Tony
Michaels for support there also don't
forget don't forget to get your the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people t-shirts it's cooling off all
right it's getting warm outside and it's
what I mean it's getting warm outside
you're gonna need some short sleeve
shirts so go to store.dtonymichaels.com
the
store.the20michaels.com and get your
t-shirts the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty oh
boy an exciting day
and we're going to be back here in just
a few minutes with the shitless Roundup
I have videos to show you and we have a
special guest here talking about the
tick tock band so stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
somebody
how's my mind
's doing okay
just Mike doing okay I don't know
yeah boy oh boy audio problems I guess
it happens
crankly again
how about now
testing testing one two testing testing
one two
oh man
choppy Mike
the whole audio yeah let's see I think I
think problem is
it's better now
yeah I don't know what's going on there
were some updates to some of the
software on my mic here lately
and I think that's um I think that's the
the problem
is probably the updates [__] it up I
don't like to do updates as if it's
working
but you know you know how it is
okay I gotta show you this um yesterday
where Donald Trump says he was indicated
I'm not getting you ah look at this [__]
he said these Thugs and radical lip
monsters have just indicated
before he hasn't deleted this by the way
it's still like this
these studs and radical left monsters
have just indicated the 45th president
of the United States of America isn't it
weird that he [__] refers to himself
this way this is it's so [__] weird
man
oh Jesus and the leading Republican
candidate by far for the 2024 nomination
for president you're the only one dude
you and Nikki Haley and this Vivek guy
that [__] piece of dumb [__]
have you heard this guy talk vivec this
guy this guy I I'm telling you I don't
know who's funding his campaign but
Donald Trump knows he has to have
opposition
in the uh in the Republican primary like
he's gonna have to have opposition and
this Vivek guy really is suspicious to
me
um but he's all over Fox News and he's
always like well I'm running against
Donald Trump wink
bring a [__] break that guy's a joke
he did he doesn't even he doesn't even
know any kind of modern history he was
talking about John Kerry one day one of
these spaces and he didn't know that his
running mate John Edwards
was actually indicted
on campaign Finance law laws crimes in
court he won
John people were playing uh or playing
the John Edwards statement that he made
outside the courthouse after he won
his trial
um over the the month the payments that
he made to his uh
his love child's mother during the
during the campaign but anyways
hell Grandpa Poopypants goes on to get
into the caps lock here
now he wasn't in caps lock in the first
part but he you know he got really
pissed off here this is an attack on our
country the
says that all the time they keep saying
like that this is the next big attack
you know I mean the likes that are I
mean you know forget Pearl Harbor right
forget 9 11. those attacks in our
country oh man this is way worse than
than that you [__] [__] me
it is likewise A continuing attack on
our once free and fair elections this
has nothing to do
with elections it has to do with you
committing fraud in your business
of which your business the Trump
organizations was found guilty by a jury
on 17 counts of criminal fraud
this is not surprising that now that
they're turning they're [__] aimed to
you personally you stupid [__]
the USA is now a third world nation a
nation in serious decline so sad
oh my God
well this is this is one for the books
folks think about this 50 60 years from
now this this is the this is the [__]
graphic people are gonna show that was
his first response after the the the
very first former president United
States the most criminal corrupt
president we've ever had in our history
this is going to be known as the [__]
graphic 50 years from now that he was
indicated
holy actual [__]
this is this is this is the history I
mean yeah we're living through it right
now we're like oh yeah he just he's just
losing his mind over on fraud social
right
but the reality is is this is what this
is going to be printed in a [__] book
somewhere all right indicated
I I mean
Gabe Sanchez I know what indicted is I
know what I know what diet it is I don't
know what an indicatement is do you know
what an indicatement is is this
something new it's a yeah actually I do
an indicatement is actually a 17th
century uh type of legal process uh in
which you have uh your you know
defendant who is typically under the law
labeled as a [__] ass [__] oh okay and
what is that official legal terminology
yeah that's that's the legalese that's
actually what's in the rule of law okay
okay um so in there you have yourself
this [__] ass [__] again that's what
it says in the actual legal documents
and how to proceed in a legal Court you
know kind of situation and in that
moment you have a [__] ass [__]
who is indicated uh for crimes you know
uh in which everyone knows that uh he's
he's guilty right or that he he did
these things and typically what happens
you know we actually saw there was a
case and it was I think it was
uh when was it
I'm trying to remember the the most
recent case I mean again this is from
17th century law but I think there was
actually a case maybe in the 1900s where
somebody did something similar
basically what happens is they kick and
scream and they whine and they they they
[__] and moan and they complain about
all these different things they actually
were found guilty uh because they
continue to do illegal things after the
illegal thing that they were uh
indicated for oh okay right well that
that makes sense that a grand jury would
indicate him yeah you gotta you got a
phone call from the guy a FaceTime from
him after now what's for after he
publicly announced he was indicated this
is after after I was this is me I'm like
on my way home right I was in I I was in
my car about to start the car and then I
got this [__] phone call they always
they always call you what is about you
do they think you're someone else or
they're just it's just so easy for them
to vent to you I don't know it's just
like I have you know I I talked to them
once you know they were like one there
was one party we were at and they got my
number and now it's like no matter no
matter how many times I block them or I
screen them or I you know I have a Spam
blocker like they always get through
right hey they're saying your Mike's
crackling uh you got the wave Elgato
right yeah it's turning it off and then
turn it on that's been working for me
like unplug it or no no just just mute
it and then unmute it
all right I'm back okay I don't know if
that is better it's it's done it's
better here
[Music]
and I'm not sure I'm not sure let me let
me play this audio see how the audio is
on this video and then we'll and then
we'll get to it
um and let me play the audio
should have known he was gonna call me
your all-time favorite President me
Trump you better not
hold me back for money again for your
league
absolute disgrace what's going on oh
you're dumbass got yourself a job
the evidence is our enemies are
desperate to stop us because they know
that we are the only ones who can stop
them they know it very strongly what
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you no they're definitely
coming after you not me do I need to
remind you that you were just in
decadent they know that we could feed
them okay you need to stop saying weak
because I am not involved in this at all
I'm just standing in their way yeah that
would be another crunch it's called
obstruction and I always will stand in
their way whatever man you do you I'm
hanging up now
and they keep saying the audio is messed
up
so here's what we're gonna do here's
yeah I can't hear you now so here's what
we're gonna do here's what we're gonna
do everyone stick in the room I promise
I'm gonna be right back Gabe you stay
right here don't go in
what
oh yeah I can't Virgo
yeah okay stay right here you stay here
I'm gonna go out and then I'm gonna come
back in and then you go out and come
back in so everyone just just hold tight
we're gonna we're gonna see if this is
gonna work I'll be I'll be right back
oh he's gone all right cool okay anyway
so while Tony's gone while Tony's gone
all right this is what we gotta do in
the chat when he comes back you gotta
say it's still a problem okay
what the [__] are you doing what what uh
okay
okay Gabe go out and come back in okay
clear Isabel are we good now
are we good now how's my audio now
oh my God
Jesus Christ okay now let's let's see if
the audio will work on the the video
here
and here's here's Sanchez again
what the [__] where the [__] do you go
oh geez oh there he is
oh [__]
oh my God
um see I think what the problem was is
the connection on my end
um
there's a tiny hand here let's see if we
can replay the um this video here from
Tiny hand Sanchez
um
how's your audio over there
uh how is it can people hear me are we
good are we good I think we're good now
I think I mean I didn't have any
problems right so okay fine yes boom
boom okay we're good I think it was I
think it was when I entered the room
originally something probably went
haywire and um so but we're good now
let's listen to this this phone call
that uh Grandpa poopy pants gave you
again okay she would have known he was
gonna call me your all-time favorite
President me Trump you better not be
calling me that for money again for your
legal defense it's an absolute disgrace
what's going on well your dumbass got
yourself trouble for committing these
crimes it's fake news the evidence says
otherwise our enemies are desperate to
stop us because they know
that we are the only ones who can stop
them and they know it very strongly what
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you no they're definitely
coming after you not me joining me
remind you that you were just indicted
they know that we can defeat them okay
you need to stop saying weak as I am not
involved in this at all I'm just
standing in their way yeah that would be
another crime it's called obstruction
and I always will stand in their way
whatever man you do you I'm hanging up
now
he's
Hell Boy they're saying the video is
still a little crankly on the sound but
you know what what the [__] are you
gonna do if you want to watch the video
if anyone would like like to watch the
video you can go to my Twitter account
at I am Gabe Sanchez or you can go to my
YouTube channel I am Gabe Sanchez
they're on both of those spots
uh if you were part of my patreon you
get a little bit of a heads up a head
start uh but on either one of those
places Twitter YouTube uh wherever I am
Gabe Sanchez you can find that video
there and you can watch it you know
until your heart explodes
I have a video here I want to show you
um now it's actually of um in front of
the courthouse just a couple hours ago
and you can see all the Maga protesters
that have showed up
um to protest they're already pissed off
um and they're in support
wait there's no one there it doesn't
look like there's anyone at the court
house look at the science reporters
it's almost like they know not to go to
Newark it feels like that it's almost
like you know what Tony you know I made
a tweet about this morning
um you know after after Trump uh was
legally searched uh by the FBI after he
stole classified documents in which he
is being investigated for by Jack Smith
and I'm sure that indictments you know
on its way
um
you know a lot of people said oh no you
really [__] poke the bear now you
guys really got the lion angry he's
gonna come out he's coming for you the
Red Wave is coming
but we didn't see any Red Wave we it was
a red tinkle a red trickle it was a red
like like a like when you
you know you know that like uh what's
what's Gleek is that what's called Gleek
when you like when the water it comes
out you know it was kind of like that
there wasn't like a faucet running or
anything it was like a slow little drip
I always [__] yeah [__] did you did
you download the update on your mic no
who's here here we go
we'll do a test
I'll talk right now and people tell me
which audio is [__]
yeah and then I'll talk now and see if
my audio is [__] I don't hear an issue
so that tells me that it's not
us like it I feel like it's It's gotta
be like wherever it's been broadcasted
to yeah
well if I shut it off and do new one we
lose the link yeah I'm not doing that
hold on hold on let me let me go to
YouTube and check this out the best the
best part about it is because it is
because our audio isn't bad
when I get on the audio version when I
actually um
download that version because I don't
hear any crackling in Gabe and he
doesn't hear any crackling in me yeah
which means our audio version being
recorded is on point it may be the
streaming software is having uh
bandwidth problems getting the signal
out to you guys but we're not having any
issues uh with sound on my end I mean
what am I gonna do though now
and we're still crackling there's still
are you hearing it on the uh are you
hearing it on YouTube no
uh okay on YouTube there's a little
crackling yeah I think it's on Facebook
too so it's it's stream yard yeah and
it's not us yeah yeah not a stream yard
stream yard's the software that man I
could not take a I could not I don't
want to be blamed for something you know
I didn't want to start my day being like
it's my fault you know uh but I'm glad
that I can uh blame someone else on this
uh being stream yard yeah well I mean
that's what I'm gonna blame it on yeah I
mean there's no other I like again I can
that's like when people said it was
there's audio problem I was like I can
hear you just fine
but when I go into YouTube I can see I
think that's what it is there's a
there's a streaming issue from from
let me see if they get it and they've
got a note here on their website to see
if it's something nope
uh I'm trying to hold on hold on hold on
what's going on here I'm trying to
invite Our Guest for the day
and is that not working and it they
can't give they're getting a 404 page
it's stream yarn that's what's happening
okay there's something going on with
stream yard
um the good news is folks is that the
likelihood is that our our recording our
recording that we're doing right now
um will be good so if that's the case
then the audio version of the when you
go download it on Apple Spotify and
Google
um it should be clear as a bill
so you'll be able to download this
episode at least here no okay so I can I
just went into another what hold on
is is it is the link working yeah I just
tried to go in and it and it was hold on
hold on hold on hold on let me let me
let me check this we're doing this on
the Fly here I open an incognito window
I'm in here and it says do I want to
give access to the camera and the audio
yes allow ass do it like you do on your
own yeah yeah what's going on
I don't know did you did it pull the
link pull the link from the uh from the
broadcast here as opposed to the one
that I sent you
maybe a link is shot and still won same
one
I have no idea
I think something's going on with stream
yard
[Music]
um
and we can go report it right now but
then we'd have to stop talking about
politics you know what I think this is
this [__] Trump this is a deep State
this is some deep State you know people
always like to talk about the Deep State
now I think that there are people
obviously that are connected higher up
that might be you know getting little
dirty fingers in there right
but when Donald Trump says oh it's the
Deep State we gotta drain the swamp that
motherfucker's been pumping the swamp
full it's been overflowing and he used
the four years he was in office to push
that further yeah see someone's saying
someone's saying up wire the broadcast
on up bar it's it's it's it's stream
yard it's the software yeah it's just
what it is and I I can't I I don't I
don't own the platform I don't own the
software and we really don't have too
many problems with this thing yeah this
is like uh this is one of those things
you know what this feels like this is
like Murphy's Law right right it's uh
what can go wrong will go wrong and so
you know our guest
maybe we should kind of to comment on
Monday but she says I mean we can come
in on she can come back on Monday if uh
she can't get in if a stream yard
problem
and there's nothing we can do to get her
in
just Hammer just tell her to come back
on Monday all right you want to tell
tell the audience who who the guest is
and what she was going to talk about
today
well so we have a guest who is some of
you may not here let me pull up you want
to pull up her yeah or Twitter yeah yeah
but first I want to show you um here is
a picture from the Trump Tower
this morning
um they're changing the name on the
Trump Tower this morning it's called the
perp tower now
so and just wanted the audience to uh
see what's going on there in New York
City now let's see if I can well I'm
trying to see I'm trying to see if maybe
she well we can try oh hey there she is
Boom there she is Boom well God damn
I think we made it work uh can she give
a thumbs up if she can hear us
yeah I'm giving it a thumbs up yeah yeah
not you dumbass
Jesus Christ I know you can hear me yeah
yeah okay okay yeah okay welcome our
guest
hey Dara how are you sorry for the uh
confusion here
yeah I mean I was already pissed that it
was this early in the morning and then
it's the same time every single day same
time every single day and then what was
it was it giving you a 404 kind of thing
yeah oh yeah I think it's extreme yard
it was working from my phone but I don't
I didn't want to like have to like I
don't want to do it
um yeah I tried it like three or four
different times and then I had to
redownload Chrome
tech support this morning yeah well I
think it's um I think it's on our end
honest you know I mean I am 100 positive
it's Gabe's fault so absolutely every
single time when when in doubt this is
this is what parents did when in doubt
just blame Gabe and then that's the
solution to getting around anyone having
to take responsibility
that's been how I've been conducting my
life for the past three years so it's
working out great yeah yeah everything's
quite well everyone's saying your audio
is great our audio sucks apparently we
don't hear it we don't hear it yeah no
you know what happens wow
girl power I guess um I want to show you
I was showing this before you came in
this is uh apparently from New York this
is uh they're changing the uh wording on
the Trump Tower and the perp Town seems
uh the same one seems are pretty on
point you know news news from New York
City I just I just want to make sure
everyone sees it
so what what are what are you here to
talk to us about today I know Tick-Tock
ban is is happening and I know this
isn't kind of on the radar today but um
we kind of plan to have you on uh anyway
so introduce yourself tell us what
you're here to talk about
um
I mean
I I
I'm trying to get him to introduce you
and he [__] won't do it Gabe will you
introduce Our Guest that you invited on
the show please yes yes yes okay go
ahead all right all right so some of you
may know her from Tick Tock some of you
may know her from Twitter she does a
really good job at uh at kicking
uh I don't want to say this
there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
she actually finds all of the bad people
online and uh and puts you know and puts
their [__] on blast for everyone to know
um and and today this is me taking a
mental health break from politics yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was just like to catch
a predator on Twitter that's what it
kind of reminds me it's just like it's
publicly shame though you're right right
right and so today today uh we wanna we
wanted to talk about Tick Tock the
restrict act we wanted to uh there's
there's some uh some some conversations
that are being talked about like who
maybe is behind the restrict act and
what the incentive is and what the the
the the uh the overreach would be right
with with it's more than just a tick
tock band
um and so
uh yeah
so so let's do this because I know the
restrict act the one thing that's
significant to me and I think that
stands out to me is that uh Senator
Warren is the the sponsor of the
restrict act
um which he is a Democrat now this is in
support of several Democrats and several
Republicans but it is being sold to us
as a tick tock ban
um but tell us more about what what it
is and what it isn't what I think I
don't know if it's so much okay well
first of all I believe it's someone fact
checked me uh 13 uh Republicans 11
Democrats won independent uh or who's
sponsoring it and it's really just like
a it's like a
technological like Patriot Act it's it's
a digital version of it and I find it to
be a bit more dangerous than
the Patriot Act
and uh I don't know if they're
I don't know if there's so much do you
guys feel like they're selling it as a
tick tock band I feel like that's a
separate thing they're using the the
um possibility of banning Tick Tock as
segue two hey we also would like to
propose this while we're here that's how
it feels to me but I'm I might I live in
my own world that's very different you
know I think I think it's uh I think I
think it's it's definitely proposed as
um
as a tick tock band
and I think that's
I think it's proposed as a tick tock ban
as a way to simplify
the way in which it's it's been it's
being thrown out there right the idea
that
if people only know at this as this one
thing then it's not going to be an issue
right like uh people won't
people know to look into it more than
what it is right if you're like oh well
it's only they're only Banning Tick Tock
then that's the real that's the real
thing we're targeting right now and
instead there's more to it and I think
it's just one of those things where it's
like if we hide what we're really doing
and we make Tick Tock the the bad guy as
opposed to
the complete overreach that is being
proposed here in this bill then I think
that's the thing where it's like they're
trying to trying to hide it right and I
I think that I think that's the main
reason why it's like it's easy to sell a
tick tock ban than easy then obviously
easier to sell a patriot act on steroids
right yeah because what it does seem
like the Patriot Act for the internet
kind of thing
um where they want to have utmost
surveillance of the internet
um which you know they had on our
Communications with the Patriot Act not
only your Communications but also like
your banking transactions and everything
else but
listen now do you think do you think
that this is any different in the uh
because I know a lot of people are
saying this is going to give them the
ability to take down anything they want
on the internet and censor the internet
the way they want but is it any
different than they have now I mean they
have the capability like for instance
when we have one of these mass shootings
and the one in particular that comes to
mind with this situation is the one that
happened in Highland Park at the parade
that that that person had a ton of
social media that was like what in the
[__] is this gang and they took it down
immediately now that might have been the
social media companies that might have
been law enforcement contacting those
social media companies to Archive for
them uh almost immediately but I mean it
was taken down almost immediately so
this idea that somehow we have control
over the internet right like us as the
people who are on the internet Tick Tock
Twitter Youtube twitch we don't have
control I mean like this morning our
audience [__] up I don't have any
control over it it's just what is
happening inside this universe so do you
think the restrict Act is to get at all
citizens and surveil us and to try to
censor the internet or do you think it
just is being
um some people on Tick Tock because
they're mad about the Tic Tac ban or
selling it that way
I I mean I feel like it's just a new
another way to have overreach and
surveyors it really feels it really does
because if you read the bow I think it's
like 55 Pages like it's not that long
but like a lot of it's kind of
open-ended and there and there's there's
an argument I've seen like online like
in Reddit and stuff where people are
like no you're misinterpreting they
they're limiting it to these countries
right but they're giving the Secretary
of Commerce like all this power to add
on countries as they see fit and what
would stop them from being like you know
what we have so much national security
threat here in the US we're going to add
ourselves on like there's nothing in
there there's no there's no wording
that's limiting that and I think it's
naive to think that it's simply for
security because if they if if Congress
truly wanted to
pass like
um
to protect our security they would pass
laws that are like comprehensive that
apply to all companies and all the
different entities that
um exist on the internet but they're not
doing that and and the Secretary of
Commerce also isn't even an elected
position and that's a that's a lot of
power for someone
so here's an argument that that I have
and again I actually do not like this
restricted personally and and I I read
part of it I did not read though 55
pages but I did read part of it and I
have
um watched a lot of videos that were for
it a lot of videos against it like
people saying hey I'm for this or ham
against this and what the reasoning was
or what some of the receipts were
um I'm actually not in favor of this
bill in particular I think we do need to
have some sort of social media built to
be quite honest
um because you know misinformation is
just running rampant and you know it's
the [__] Wild West and until we
actually know what's what is and what
isn't real in truth anymore then then
we'll get into a better position but I
don't think this is the bill to do that
but I think the argument here is what
you're saying about the Secretary of
Commerce because even though the
Secretary of Commerce isn't an elected
official they are appointed by who we
elect and but what what the bill seems
to do is not only give the Secretary of
Commerce a lot of power but he's giving
people who are appointed by him or her a
lot of power right so the Secretary of
Commerce has this has this the ability
to develop this board which makes a lot
of these decisions and they do it behind
closed doors without any public
accountability as it seems in the bill
because it's it's very broad right and
there's no specific details into that
but this is an argument more of why it
is so important that we actually take
serious and put serious people in the
House of Representatives
for so many years and decades the house
are Representatives was really our
government right that was our voice even
even
um before the Senate became elected
officials they were appointed in the
states they weren't even elected by a
senators or not
um and the president didn't have a lot
of power executive power until FDR came
in uh to office and he kind of changed
the presidency into what the modern
presidents the Executive offices today
that we think of but I think this is the
argument to give the power more back to
the people to the House of
Representatives but the problem is the
problem is is we have dumb [__] like
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren bobert Matt
gatz who couldn't work their way out of
a wet paper sack and also we have people
like Jim Comer and Jim Jordan as as the
the [__] chairman of the oversight
which is terrifying that a q anoner Jim
Comer is the [__] chairman of the
oversight committee and then Jim Jordan
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan is
the [__] chairman of the Judiciary
committee so until our country can get
into a position where we know our Civics
we know our government we know the
functions of it and we give our the
power back to ourselves which giving the
power back to ourselves is taking away
from the Executive Branch the Secretary
of Commerce and giving it back to the
House of Representatives where it truly
the power of our government belongs
because we get to hold them accountable
every two years they have a they have a
two-year term limit everyone speaks of
term limits they have a two-year term
limit we get to term them out we can
fire them if they're not doing their job
but as long as we continue this road of
delusion
and we can't elect serious people we
have this problem with where the power
lies so I guess the question is would
you rather the Secretary of Commerce
have this power or would you rather the
moglodytes in the House of
Representatives to have this power
are you asking me yes oh uh I wasn't
sure if it was just like an open-ended
like no no I I don't
I don't know honestly I don't really
trust even our elected officials
Judgment of character judgment uh of
others like I just don't I don't really
trust even the seemingly best people
that we elect I think a lot of them are
corporate I mean look at half the
Democratic party more than half the
majority is their corporate they they're
sponsored by look at Chuck Schumer who's
sponsored by heavily by big Pharma I
mean we can't
you know I
I just think that
in overall
the there are other ways to go about
handling security risks with data and
this is not in my opinion the best way
and I'm not professional at all I'm just
um well I know I think I mean I think
that's a good point like you know um on
today's episode of what the actual [__]
up I'm gonna I'm gonna play this yeah so
we gotta we've got a video uh that we're
gonna play in a second but I think
there's a good point that's made there
which is like you know I think with any
elected official we we should be we we
shouldn't buy into them just obviously
because they're our party affiliation
right like whoever they might be
obviously the you know certain people
who are in control into the oversight
committee or what have you Jim comer or
Margaret Taylor green or whatever but
then there's other you know there's
other Democrats who take in you know
special interest money right they're not
always going to be working at the best
interest and that's something else like
if we even look at this restrict act
right like those who may support that we
got to get rid of The Tick Tock band or
we gotta we have to implement a tick
tock ban because
uh because it's bad for these many
reasons but if you look at you know
Facebook or you know that they've got
Instagram and Facebook and uh if we look
at Twitter especially right these are
all other apps that have security
concerns you know we've got a private
citizen like Elon Musk who has control
of this social network and he can do
whatever he wants with it and we've got
some of the people who helped him with
the like come up with the funds weren't
they like foreign oh yeah and that's
another thing right like you look you
look at that you've got Saudi money
you've got money coming from other
places you've got you know everyone you
know if you look if I'm sure that if you
looked at the financials you'd see that
other you know certain people on both
sides have their kind of hands in on all
these different pots right they're
hedging their bets as to how things are
going to play out and you know when it
comes to this specific thing right we
you know people call it the the Patriot
Act on steroids or they call it
um I mean that's what it really is right
like it's it's uh it's this accelerated
version this for people who went through
911 right we had the Patriot Act that
came after and that was you know this
balance or unbalance of if you want more
security you have to give up privacy
right that's the that's the the way that
that things uh come out and and this is
another one where it's very open-ended
right like the ability we already know
that obviously we're all monitored in
some way and this is something that
would really take it to extreme and also
have punishment you know repercussions
too
right
in the bill if I don't know how far into
it it is or where anyone gotten it but I
it really is at their discretion to
determine if something is a foreign
threat or not and what would stop anyone
from applying that to
police body cam footage too because they
could you could twist that with the
mental gymnastics you could do you could
be like well this person is friends with
uh uh someone in China has a relative so
now they're a national security so we're
gonna cut the body cam footage it can't
be shown we can't release it like
there's a lot of vagueness that when you
really think about it can be dangerous
to us and would put us in a situation
where it's like North korea-esque which
is Extreme but still I'm using that as
to be dramatic but there's a yeah so
there's a there's a video that you
provided uh from from I I don't know her
name but uh but in this video they talk
about
or two videos rather but they talk about
the reaper like one of the things I
didn't know was the whole VPN side right
and the the
uh well here we'll just play the video
we'll explain what a VPN is first so a
VPN people can uh all right so
um a VPN you can use like say it in
hillbilly damn it say it in hillbilly if
you want to act if you want to let's say
okay here's an example let's say you
want to access Netflix because Netflix
has certain rights to property like a
movie that's in another country you want
to use the VPN to access that version of
Netflix let's say so I say oh you know
what it's only accessible in Italy so I
have to use a VPN
so I'm in the U.S but the VPN will make
it look like I'm in Italy so I can
access those things so it's like an
address it's like an address marker to
where you can actually so let's say you
want to be on Netflix Italy yeah the
address marker which is the VPN so that
way Netflix says oh they're in Italy so
I'm gonna feed them the Italy Netflix
version and so right now physically I'm
physically in the U.S but I'm virtually
right it's a virtual private Network I'm
in Italy and so if I use that so the
whole theory was if I am in a different
country and then the one in which Tick
Tock or some app is banned then I can
easily use that
to use it in another country right so
people like oh well if we ban it in the
U.S then I can use the I can use the VPN
on my phone to say that I'm in Japan or
I'm in Germany or some other country
right they're going to make that illegal
well there's it's not that it's illegal
another issue right then does that tack
on another charge if you are using a VPN
and you're accessing stuff content that
they deemed illegal and now using a VPN
might be illegal and there it's it's so
vague that this could actually like
something that like let's say like um
like pirating if you're like pirating
movies right you would just get hit with
the fact that you're you're illegal like
bootleg movies but not a VPN charge in
this case
it's the wording's vague enough that you
could be hit with a charge for a
separate charge for using a VPN so and
the and the company itself would also be
responsible because you allowed which is
a whole thing where it's like
I you know how do you even
control that right like then vpns
wouldn't be able to exist anymore
because you wouldn't be able to know
that this person was bypassing whatever
uh local
law was in place to get around it and it
becomes this very murky like I I anyway
I'm gonna go to jail yeah pretty much
let's let's play the video let's let's
see how what her take on it is on
today's episode of what the actual [__]
the complete destruction of the internet
as we know it I'm talking about Bill
s686 the restrict act and if you care
about your freedom you need to listen to
this this bill is the Patriot Act on
steroids it allows the president the
ability to choose a secretary of
communications that can have an Advisory
Board none of these people who are
elected who can have closed-door
meetings meaning the public is not privy
to it cannot attend they don't even have
to put it in writing who can decide what
they do and do not want to allow on the
internet not just apps like Tick Tock
everything from Wireless local networks
to mobile networks to satellite payloads
to gaming applications payment
applications everything let me give you
an example if they decided that they
don't want criticism of the U.S
government on the internet
they can go through your instant
messages all of your content if you have
an Etsy shop with something that sells
black lives matter shirts and they
decide they don't want anyone talking
about black lives matter if you're
following subreddits on Reddit that are
critical of the government and they
decided you can't be you could be
imprisoned for 20 years
okay so she's kind of taking the
ultimate dramatic take here right to the
ultimate extreme
um now I don't think it's the actual
intent of The Rustic strict act but it
is the possibility right so I think I
think that's the concern that most
people have is not the original intent
because like the Patriot Act you know
yeah it's it's funny that um there's a
former uh house speaker that was
actually put in prison
over the the Patriot Act that he pushed
which I'm sure when um
when that's house speaker was making
that uh pushing that the Patriot Act
through uh for the security of the
nation his idea wasn't well one day I'll
go to prison
um because of the Patriot Act because a
bank um a bank transactions that I was
making as in hush money payments
um to someone who was trying to extort
me
um I I didn't I don't I don't think that
he thought that that was going to be the
intent and I think that's most people
concerned especially people on Tick Tock
because this is a person on Tick Tock
and this is why um on Tick Tock it seems
so at the Forefront because they do want
to ban that app that there is no
question our government officials
especially the elected ones want to ban
Tick Tock now whether you agree with it
or disagree with it the fact Still
Remains they're hell-bent on
um Banning it now rather that ban or the
push for that ban is the reason why they
want to push this restrict act or not
and then how far does it go but the
thing is is that I think being loud
about it
um actually calling your Senator calling
your Congressman no matter if they're
Republican or Democrat and saying hey
we want you to make the internet safe
because I don't think anyone wants the
internet to be unsafe and I don't think
that's I mean there are some people out
there but I do they're better
but they're bad at most people who want
it to be unsafe intentionally are are
using it as bad actors
um but in in in in most cases most
people want the internet to be safe but
this idea because with this Tick Tock
band because I listened to part of the I
I listen to the opening statement
of The Tick Tock CEO I also listen to
some of the questioning
and this idea that apps like Facebook uh
YouTube uh uh Instagram
um Google are not capturing like your
keystrokes because if you go to The Tick
Tock um in terms of service right and
you actually look at them Tick Tock is
is tracking your keystrokes they know
what the [__] you're typing when you're
typing it they know all about our type
of right that's embarrassing right
exactly but it's not just Tick Tock that
knows that it's not just Tick Tock that
knows that and and that I think is the
main key so
she's making a very good argument now I
I think she is again she is trying to
take the Most Extreme Measures that this
bill could absolutely place on the
American people
and she's using that as the reason not
to support it
um the same way that politicians in
particular some of the Senators uh even
Democratic senators are using to say
tick tocks collecting all your
information on your children well yeah
but every other [__] app they're
using is too right every single one of
them have these types of terms of
services and this uh surveillance over
you well so much of what Congress
brought up
well it was parenting like it was just
parenting [__] like what are you doing
saying where the audacity that any
member of government even has to get up
there and publicly be like well kids are
spending too much time at
I mean that's a [__] parenting issue
who the hell are you to step in and say
anything in even comments about it like
a lot of that was very very absurd and a
lot of the issues as far as with
children is concerned it's parenting
like if you don't you know you should be
supervising your children to an extent
depending on their age you should be
overseeing like you if someone's giving
their kids free reign I mean that's
that's I don't agree with it but that is
a parenting choice and Congress really
doesn't have any business any business
talking about it at all addressing it in
any way well I think you bring up a good
point because I think that's also
related to you know when we've uh we've
got the parent the
the the parental rights act right which
is the thing that Republicans want to
push because which it you know the don't
say gay bill right in Florida like
things like that they're trying to say
that
you know they're taking the rights away
from parents and parents aren't able to
have the discussions or this or that and
it's like look
nobody took these rights away from you
it's how you decided to handle you you
decided you couldn't be bothered to
answer an email from a teacher about
some issue or dealing with this I know
that obviously you have kids and so you
know being active in your kids life is
something that's important especially if
you want to have a say in in their
education right and so when parents like
you know when you have members of
Congress you know or other other
legislators that want to say oh well
tick tock's bad because it allows this
right and then you have the tick tock
CEO saying look we have preventions in
place but we can't make you tap those
buttons when it's on your app right like
we give it to you and we tell you we
have a whole section that's that's for
parents right and how they want to
handle just like any other app right
which is
we have time limit restrictions we have
what uh what websites you can go to
um we have you know when is the safe
period you want to make sure that uh
certain uh ports are closed so that you
know you can't get all of a sudden a
random message or an airdrop photo or
whatever it is right these are things
that we put in place to say hey these
are features that you can enable
but you can't go and blame the CEO for
saying some issue right like it I forgot
who it was but
some idiotic or moronic statement which
was like oh how do you do some connected
with the Wi-Fi and the connection and
it's like those are unrelated things
entirely what Boomers Boomers right
right and it's it's just it's
basically it's just them trying to again
place blame on something else that that
is not the actual problem well the other
the other thing the other thing too is
that when when some of these questions
are being asked in Congress I'm like gee
Jesus Christ can they learn how the
internet works before they ask questions
about the internet for Grant out loud
they're like what is email type [__]
like are you kidding me like it's on us
this is on us as Millennials we did this
we taught them we taught the Boomers how
to use the internet and this is what
we're getting this is this is payback
this is why no good deed goes unpunished
I just I think back to when I uh like as
a as a millennial right anytime I go
back home after you know on break for
school or whatever my dad or my mom
would be like hey this thing is broken
electronic wise or I can't do this on
the computer or whatever my VCR won't
record like uh you know this isn't this
isn't powering up or this isn't working
or I did this and then you know the
frustration of having to be uh you know
unpaid tech support in your own home and
trying to fix things and there's
some of it I think goes to like not
being willing to or or the patience
right I think patience is a big thing
when you're like why can't you just get
it right like for us it was we were
literally born you know we we were born
through it right and we got instant
messenger then we got you know more of
the internet and this and this and that
and all and we just kind of like learn
to adapt
and with our parents they were like
what's that thing you're on right now or
what's this I don't really understand it
can you explain it to me and you're like
God why don't you get it you know and
it's the patience aspect right now
because I remember trying to teach my
grandpa how to use email and I was like
clicking and doing this and he's like
whoa whoa whoa slow down there champ how
do we do this and I'm like
yeah all right um
and really I mean honestly if I think if
we had better patients or we were better
teachers or understanding right for us
we just got it we just we just
understood but yeah because we grew up
with the internet right we had the damn
dialogue sound someone said someone said
to be fair Tony is kind of a boomer
still what the [__] does that mean
maybe you're giving Boomer energy well I
do take some Boomer energy yeah we could
take a vote and we could we could ask
hey well there is several times when
Gabe you know he'll I just like I told
him I'm like slow down talk hillbilly
and he's like okay Boomer you know like
when we're texting about something
because I'm asking him what the [__] is
this why the hell is this like this
because I don't know everything I mean I
should but I don't know I was I I had a
former boss and uh
and he was telling me a story about his
kid and they were out I think on
vacation or whatever and they had you
know they gave their kid an iPad and uh
the kid was like
why can't I get like where's the
internet where like they just they just
right now because they don't understand
like what we went through in terms of
uh growing up with the internet but it's
it's right now where these kids are
growing up and they like automatically
maybe this is true for your kids too
where they're like you know maybe early
on they pension Zoom photos or stuff
like that like there's been some
research where they've seen uh some
younger children
see that behavior and they learn it so
then when they see photos or like there
was I think there was like I already
know where this is
like right and so the pinch and zoom is
a total obviously a totally learned
behavior wait wait wait wait wait wait
I'm trying to look up something here are
you two talking about you pinch and zoom
on a piece of paper yeah so yeah just
put your [__] readers on things put
your [__] readers on there that's a
that's a boomerang
leaders uh readers what's your reader I
don't I I I yeah yeah but all I mean all
jokes aside I I know that you know
people in the comments are like don't
drag Boomers or whatever I all jokes
aside we all have to tell us what to do
our our audience our audiences is uh
full of the boomer generation and we
love Hamming them they're the best
audience in the world but you know what
they do
um they respect not only the millennial
generation but also gen Z the Boomers at
our show they respect those Generations
because they see them as the the the
generation of the generations of the
internet we're like the we're like the
OG internet generation right yeah kind
of the pioneer right you know we grew up
through right you know dialogue internet
right and it happened it takes like 15
minutes to download a nudie pic uh off a
porno site what what you didn't do that
I don't care yeah well it's don't J
don't say yeah Gabe like you weren't in
there uh you know it yeah okay takes
like 20 minutes to get down to the to
the boobage you know I mean you might
have to go outside play a few games of
basketball come in you know drink some
juice boxes and have some cookies and
then and then finally your 13 year old
dreams have come true here uh on the
internet screen okay so uh it looks like
Lindsey Graham and I know I'm skipping
uh here and um I know we're supposed to
talk about Tick Tock but it's lit did
Lindsey Graham tweet
that um yeah they should go smash
Windows is that what the [__] is that is
that really a thing is that is what's
happening uh yesterday yeah yeah he
really said that he basically said uh
Boomers shouldn't be on the internet
yeah that's a good example no yeah the
idea that I mean Donald Trump is the
epitome of that uh but yeah Lindsey
Graham said and maybe he deleted it but
he definitely said No it's it's I'm
gonna put I'm okay up here this is him
reacting to the indictment uh how can
president Trump avoid prosecution in New
York hmm he's pondering uh on the way to
Diaz DA's office on Tuesday uh Trump
should smash some windows rob a few
shops and punch a cop he would be
released immediately I I don't know he's
joking it's not a good joke I'm not
saying that well are they good at joking
are they good at comedy yeah really no
well this is the I mean this is the this
is the well okay so this is something
with the internet right like you say
something on the Internet and your voice
or rather the companies
image as Twitter is safe
from somebody saying something like this
right however it's interpreted sarcasm
or real you know enter the the internet
company be like oh well that's that's
them that's not us so we're not actually
liable for this right and that's
that and that's in section 230 if you
look at that that's something else that
with the restrict act that would be
obviously looked at
um I mean the restrict Act was or sorry
the the section 230 was created in 90
95 I want to say sure sounds good I
don't know it I mean it's like it's
almost 30 years old right yeah it's
something that sure it's it's a it's a
it's something that should be updated
for how the internet is changing but
should not be done in a way that is this
overarching control right
yeah yeah go ahead
attack though Lindsay's tweet right
there could be deemed National Security
it's by discretion and right there he
could be facing charges so and I don't
agree with that I think that he's
allowed to make that make that really
terrible joke I mean he might have
giggled at it no one else is but he
thinks it's funny so let him do it you
know I think that right there is a good
example of what could possibly be
determined to be uh security risk enough
to face charges and possibly you know
the odds of someone getting making a
crappy tweet like that and getting hit
with a million dollar fine and 20 years
in jail is unlikely but you know it's
not it wouldn't be impossible right this
alone this law allows it is is I think
the main point that everyone should be
making is that is that there is a
slippery slope here with this law that
could happen everyone go follow Dara
here on uh on Twitter if you wanna if
you want to see all the the great bio
and
um if ever well now you know it's live
on air you you can update it but if you
want to go watch some um see your tweets
on how she calls out all the uh the
pedophiles out there not just cops
teachers but uh although it is it is I
gotta say you know when it comes to
Darth like uh content it is funny to see
how triggered people get right
especially when you like hey look here's
a bad person I'm calling them out and
you know typically you'll see a lot of
Republicans
why are you doing you know it's kind of
like when I say the word Nazi and they
all get [__] they all freak out and
you can't say that I'm like okay Nazi I
was talking to you so well the best part
is the people who are not uh Republican
but they and they don't want to
completely hate the cops so they'll go
in and they'll nitpick my words or my
jokes that I put within oh yeah yeah and
they'll nitpick at them like hold on so
like are you defending the pastor or the
cop or what's going on here it's like
they they back themselves into a quarter
but no one gets triggered more than
Boomers on my satiricals
there she is aiming at Buddhism thanks
for joining us today I appreciate it uh
come back anytime and let's talk more
about this restrict act as it uh as it
comes up in the The Tick Tock band
everyone stick around I hope our audio
is still good when we come back we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
we're in the second hour of the show you
know what that means on Friday
and of course you know I want to talk
about Donald Trump and his indictment
and you did not let us down
a previously undefeated competitor
has finally reached
her point of defeat bonehead of the week
bonehead of the week oh my God
you know people oh well go anyway yeah I
was gonna say if if you don't follow
Dara you should go to her go to her
profile on on Twitter on Tick Tock
Instagram Instagram all that content you
can get there like I said she does a
really good job at calling out the bad
guys the pedos uh
then and also make some pretty good
videos she does it like she I think she
does weekly Recaps of those as well like
the tweets her and another uh another
person also goes through
um
and calls them out and he's like hey
here are the things that you missed
right and it's and especially and I
wanted to bring up this when she was
here but especially because you know we
have Republicans who want to say oh it's
the it's the drag queens and it's this
and this and that right and then you
know Dara and others will be like hey
um look at all these drag queens that
cause these problems and it's never the
drag queen never the drag queen right
and we should understand that because
it's all projection from the right you
know okay so let's get to bonehead of
the week
um of course the most bone-headed of the
bonehead uh in the in the boneheads that
there is in bonehead land uh landed on
bonehead of the week but let's start the
music and let's get to bonehead of the
week
[Music]
[Applause]
brown head of the week here's our
contestants
Donald J Trump J for ridiculous the J is
science and then what we said the other
day ridiculous no it was something what
Donald Trump yeah are the J is for
ridiculous the J is silent or something
like that I don't remember ah
representative Lauren bobert
she's on the list so as representative
Marjorie Taylor green uh is on the
bonehead list this morning now you
obviously Marjorie Taylor green has been
undefeated in the past but Gabe Sanchez
uh she did not win this poll she has now
been defeated in the bonehead of the
week pull yeah and I believe it I'm
trying to remember if she's ever gone
against
against Trump before
I well I don't know I don't I don't know
but Marjorie Taylor green has been
defeated this week
um but you know the funny part is we put
her on for some other dumb [__] but she
did some dumb [__] this morning she said
that she was gonna go to New York City
you know what you know what I hope that
she does I hope I said I hope that she
does I hope that she does go to New York
City because yummy look
the party of Law and Order the party of
just comply the party of don't resist
the party of uh do the crime do the time
right now these people want to claim
that this is a totally political Witch
Hunt and it's unconstitutional do he
committed a crime
he's got to follow through look if he's
actually innocent and I've said this
before if he is innocent
then all that he has to do
is make the case
and if he truly is innocent then I'm
sure
that his defense
will do that right again I don't think
that he is but everyone you know is
innocent until proven guilty right and
so in the court of law if he makes the
case and presents before the jury and
and his lawyers actually prove that it's
not what the prosecution and the D.A are
claiming it is
then that's all that has to be done
right like
it's funny to see Republicans complain
about an unfair two-tier justice system
now
when we have countless people
who are sentenced or convicted of crimes
that either
were never there to begin with uh wasn't
as bad as it was or were put in a place
that makes them seem
uh worse than it is right and so it's
just funny to see Republicans now be
like oh no this is totally unfair
unconstitutional it's like well you
might want to look at the justice of
itself
and go back to all of these other people
in other communities who don't have
money and who aren't white and who don't
have access to the same types of
resources that you might have that can
get you out of this um you know
crime
well she says I'm going to New York on
Tuesday we must protest this
unconstitutional Witch Hunt is what she
types out here now the problem with the
word unconstitutional is she's acting as
if the people in Manhattan didn't vote
for Alvin Bragg and Alvin Bragg isn't
the actual
seated
district attorney in Manhattan she's
also acting like that this wasn't a
grand jury that voted for these what we
know right now is 34 at the least
business fraud charges
they voted for those right Alvin Bragg
didn't bring these charges himself he
went to a grand jury
yeah the other people think that it's
all him like he did this right you know
it he presented a case and and I do want
to say there's a lot of people out there
who want to who want to claim to start I
you know I heard it in the in Twitter
spaces yesterday they're like oh there
was no defense there was no one that was
brought into the grand jury to defend
Donald Trump and reform that was last
Monday you're right right refute the
case and so I said
uh uh that's well I I said it to a few
people but also some people brought it
up in the space because here's the thing
you gotta remember uh kellyanne Conway
she's she even openly admitted on Pierce
Morgan that she was brought in right you
had uh
Costello was brought in right you you
had so were these people so are they
saying because it sounds like they're
saying these people were against Donald
Trump and if Kelly and Conway hope Hicks
and Costello are against Trump then he's
really [__] well because the argument
that they're trying to make is they're
saying that Donald Trump is being you
know persecuted for this crime right
what's so bad some people are like oh
yeah we can talk about the morality of
it and all the stuff but like as a crime
it's a business but all this [__]
so the argument that people are making
and if I even saw some lawyers make this
argument last night which I'm like how
dumb are you guys the argument that
they're trying to push Sean Hannity was
trying to do it last night too on a show
and what they're they have that clip can
you find that clip go no go ahead say
what he was going to say and then the
narrative that they're trying to push is
that when you have a grand jury because
they keep going oh anyone can indict a
ham sandwich like that's that's one
statement they they say and they're like
the um
the the tier or or The Benchmark or
um
um the The Benchmark for what is
acceptable to put someone uh you know a
grand jury and then and then and convict
them is so low and so with that you've
got a situation like Donald Trump and
really what they're trying to do is
they're trying to make it seem like he's
worse than he is
and specifically when you do these grand
juries the prosecution brings in all of
these people to say hey look grand jury
this person's bad okay okay can you pull
that clip of Sean Hannity I want to
explain to people this [__] grand
jury process and this [__] okay the only
thing a grand jury is designed to do is
to take the probable cause problem out
of a prosecutor's hand because the
probable cause problem is if the
prosecutor decides what probable cause
is or isn't that's when the ham sandwich
can be indicted right now when you go to
a grand jury the bar is low for probable
cause I don't know if people know this
out there but I and a business of mine
have been indicted by a grand jury
that's right I have been indicted my
business was indicted by a grand jury
and I was indicted by a grand jury a
year after okay I this has been years
ago I'm not going to get into the
details today of exactly what it is but
trust me when I say this
there is nothing that Donald Trump is
going to do in a court that is going to
undo a grand jury's indictment that is
why prosecutors use grand juries
prosecutors do not have to use grand
juries Alvin Bragg could have brought
these charges all on his [__] own for
the probable cause that he wanted to
state is the probable cause but what
Alvin Bragg also wants to do in the
court of law is to make sure these
indictments do not get thrown
and the way that they don't get thrown
is Alvin Bragg proves that he presented
his case for probable cause to a grand
jury
it's not [__] complicated to
understand these things yes is it a low
Bar for a probable cause sure it is
Alvin Bragg could have brought these
cases could have brought these charges
without the grand jury with his what he
deemed as probable cause but he not only
took the time and the measure and to
call witnesses before a grand jury to
make sure
that the grand jury understood all the
evidence that he had so that they could
determine if there was a probable cause
for him to continue with these charges
and they said yes that's the process
that's how it works Donald Trump was not
afforded any extra privilege or less a
privilege from the grand jury or Alvin
Bragg here the craziest part to me is
that Alvin Bragg since he's been the D.A
has brought 117 cases before grand
juries about business fraud
this is just one of them the reason why
the grand jury is going to go on recess
you know all they were like oh the grand
jury they're going to decide not to
indict and that's why they're pausing it
no this grand jury is seeing more cases
and determining probable cause in other
cases not just the Trump case when a D.A
especially a state D.A convenes a grand
jury they normally present several cases
that they would like to get probable
cause for an indictment in front of that
grand jury they present many cases to
them over several months and they give
that grand jury breaks and periods
during that several months to take
breaks it's not [__] complicated
stuff it really isn't to know what a
grand jury is whether it's a Federal
grand jury or a state grand jury the
same thing is happening in Georgia the
same [__] thing is happening in
a Federal grand jury in Washington D.C
where Jack Smith is presenting his case
for for probable cause for indictments
this is the most bone-headed [__] I have
ever heard in my [__] life to say
that this process is a Witch Hunt number
one an unconstitutional number two you
are a [__] idiot just a [__]
bonehead either that or your alliance
sack of garbage which I believe Marjorie
Taylor green is both what I mean 100
every one of them that try to push this
this this concept of it's a uh you're
politicizing this like let's let's
understand the fact
that Donald a lot of this stuff
about Donald Trump being indicted or or
Donald Trump being again Mar-A-Lago we
didn't know about it until he posted
about it you know this indictment we
didn't know I mean we knew that the
grand jury was there we didn't think
that or or no rather when he was going
to get indicted he's the one who put a
week and a half ago Tuesday on the map
for everyone
and then fundraised and grifted off of
it right and then finally a little bit
later because there's a whole thing
about like I was talking to you
yesterday I was like oh yesterday they
just said
that they were taking a month off and I
I have a theory because I was under I
was listening to a couple lawyers talk
about this they were like the point at
which it becomes there's a point at
which the grand jury makes the decision
and then there's this lapse in time
where the D.A then takes it down to
wherever this office right follows it
with the clerk so exactly and then
actually serve and arrange the
indictments and then at that point
that's when it's official and gets out
there and so like oh there's some
theories which sounds about right
which is the indictment happened on
Monday right they voted on it
nobody knew about it and then when it
was filed with the clerk that's when
everyone knew about it which was
yesterday so that was about it was like
20 hours later or something that they
officially like processed it
um
and so it makes sense why the Manhattan
D.A were like we're going to take a
month off break right now and everyone's
like wait what the [__] going on you
know Republicans are like huh they don't
they don't have a case they got nothing
there they're not going to indict and
then you know people on the left are
like wait why are we taking a break
what's going on right like because
they're gonna see other cases right
right and so if Alan Alvin Bragg is
going to bring cases that have nothing
to do with Donald Trump to this grand
jury yeah and have them vote on charges
of cases because he's a [__]
prosecutor his his only job isn't to
prosecute Donald Trump folks that's not
his only job his job is to prosecute and
have his office execute those
prosecutions in the the
jurisdiction of Manhattan now uh let's
show this clip of Sean Hannity and see
what he says it's only 49 seconds and
then I want to show you
um the actual statement actually you
know we'll wait till we get to the
Donald Trump portion of this to show the
album Bragg uh uh statement to Jim the
Jimbo's GM I don't report sex crime
Jordan and Jim Q Anon Comer let's listen
to uh Hannity spew up his bio here now a
low-level felony that is so weak so
convoluted and possibly even outside the
statute of limitations he doesn't know
any of that not not not a [__] thing
you don't know what they're charging
what business fraud they're charging for
you are so this is so [__] stupid
this is ridiculous and it's face that a
a a host of a TV show would even say
this stupid [__] right I don't know what
the charges are you have no clue and to
definitively say that this is you know
Injustice because I don't know the
charges and I don't know why they're
charging him with these things and I
don't even know the crimes but it's
biased come on
that a grand jury in deep blue New York
City right very well and seems to be
rejecting it now keep in mind you can
indict a ham sandwich in a grand jury
you don't need a unanimous verdict and
the only and only the prosecution gets
to present evidence in other words the
defense gets zero opportunity to even
speak to the grand jury let alone
present any evidence that they have
that's [__] they invited Donald
Trump to come speak which again a great
a prosecutor a prosecutor can allow the
other side to come make their case or
the prosecutor can just say I'm going to
make my case and let you [__] vote
that's why they say they can indict a
ham sandwich because I'm not in
disagreement that that a prosecutor can
use the evidence in a way to make the
grand jury vote they want the way they
want to vote but what people aren't
understanding about the grand jury is
the grand jury has the right to question
the prosecutor they have the right to
gather their own [__] evidence if
they want to rebut the evidence that the
prosecutor is presenting them they have
that opportunity
and this Grand Jury has been looking at
this case for months not days not hours
months and they decided that they would
indict Donald Trump on at least 34
charges I don't know if there's more we
just right I mean I think I think I saw
um a couple people say today that there
was roughly 30 which if you think about
it right there's 11 payments now and
this is this is totally I'm making an
assumption here right you've got 11
payments that were made now are there
multiple charges per payment kind of
thing are these out you know are there
more that is it more than just those 11
payments that were made that the charges
were you know tacked onto we don't know
because it's a sealed indictment and we
won't know for probably a few days I had
if I had to guess like I don't know
probably released on Monday or sometime
next week I could be wrong it could be
sooner
but you know when when you hear Sean
Hannity say oh well uh we don't
uh the the the prosecution is the only
one who brings this this forward and
they bring
Witnesses and they make the case and the
defense can't do anything that's again
that's totally untrue because what
happened was the defense did bring
people in right they brought multiple
people in to refute or to uh challenge
the claims that were made by Cohen and
by [__] you had well pecker came in
at the end for like the kind of cherry
on the top there and if anyone know
pecker who is the uh owner of the uh
National Enquirer right which is where
the whole
story was going to leak originally then
the then the payoff was made and well
more than just one story right right
right and so there's the whole thing of
how to benefit Donald Trump you know
going in but now you've got Packer
coming I don't even think
and if I think
I remember correctly they said neither
the defense nor the prosecution like
they didn't call them in as a witness
if I remember correctly which means I
don't know if that was him like uh
volunteering to say like hey I want to
present or I want to say something I'm
not sure how that worked but I think
what I saw last week was it was neither
one of them uh that invited him I guess
I don't know the point is is that can a
grand jury
indeed a ham sandwich yes because
another analogy would be a drug dog at a
traffic stop right so think of the the
drug dog as the grand jury where the cop
that has the dog can lead the dog around
give it certain commands to give them
probable cause to search your [__]
vehicle for crimes you may have
committed and possibly charge you with
crimes right the grand jury is the same
way but again it's a third party source
that they're using to make sure that
this [__] sticks in court the only
reason why Alvin Bragg uses the grand
juries because number one he's in
Manhattan right this is this is uh one
of the one of the largest districts
um that a district attorney has in the
country and one of the largest cities
in our nation right so this is not this
is not Amateur hour there at the
Manhattan DA's office
um and Alvin Bragg shows it now I'm
going to show you um uh we're gonna skip
around here yeah but then we're going to
come right back to this I got to go to
bobert here but maybe I'll tie maybe
I'll tie this in because this clip here
really um she tries to act like she's a
lawyer in this clip that she made it she
made a complete embarrassment of herself
this week when she's talking about
public urination she's she's trying to
question members of the uh the
Washington D.C city council about public
urination she totally fails really
honestly I something deep down inside of
me really wish that Lauren bobert had
her law license and she would go defend
Donald Trump it honestly reminds me of
um I think it might have been an eighth
grade or or maybe uh
freshman year in high school we did
these like mock trials you know where
you're like hey
um here are these crimes that were
committed you're on the defense you're
on the prosecution right you have to
make these cases and I remember too many
times where somebody on either side you
know on either team I was on would go up
and would try to do something similar to
what Lauren bobert did right and it'd be
like dude did you [__] read the text
like did you did you actually look at
the record because they're on like and
you also know
you know if there really was a trial
right you do know what they did say
right and you obviously you don't want
to like repeat the same type of outcome
or there are rather uh don't repeat the
same type of um
answers or whatever but if you do read
the text then you know like I should ask
this question or or this is the
knowledge I have give me context of what
I was privy to as that character right
and this is one of those situations
where Lauren bober like in one of those
mock trials like she tries to act like
an attorney
and and present information or research
and then be like oh actually I didn't
read anything past like the preface
right of the of like this story though
they actually found her on like a talent
site because and she does this where she
goes and she acts like a preacher you've
seen these videos that picture takes
where she's she's strutting around on
stage you know preaching the Bible she
doesn't understand half of it and she's
strutting around and she's acting like a
preacher and then she comes into this
Committee hearing questioning uh members
of the city council Washington DC about
the public hearing nation of all things
in this week where the former presidents
being indicted we had a we had a school
shooting in Nashville where three
children three teachers were killed
um there's huge protest in in the
Tennessee State Capitol and a peaceful
protest the the peaceful Insurrection
there at the end Tennessee the ones that
the police let in right right well
there's a video of like people like oh
man there's storming the capital right
they're not they were singing Let It
Shine they're singing Let It Shine and
also like the police let them in and
they they're not beating them up they
aren't beating them flat they're not
they're not yeah they're not breaking
windows or breaking doors they didn't
make a spear out of a flag didn't bring
weapons none of them they're actually
what they're doing is protesting weapons
of war and they're singing uh Let It
Shine and we can play part of that later
on the show but I want to play this uh
Lauren bobert acting like an attorney
here and it fails miserably can you
imagine let's watch it Mr Allen
based on these statistics
I I would like to talk to you
um about some some other things that are
going on here in Washington DC
specifically an initiative that you led
in November of 2022. so she said
statistics
isn't it I think she said it because
it's a big word what does statistics
have to do with this questioning that
she hands I don't know she never really
brings up any statistics or data no I
don't think so because like if you were
to be like oh hey look look let's look
at the statistics here let's look at the
stats right the numbers which you need
to be talking about the stats of public
urination is that what she would okay
you would assume that if you're talking
about the topic of public urination that
if you're gonna discuss and you were uh
four
four penalty right you're you're for
someone getting charged with a fine or a
crime or something like that you think
you would think that your argument would
say there is not enough penalty right
like there's 67 percent of people
whatever are publicly urinating that's a
lot of people but who knows uh are
publicly urinating in this District
right this area
and only 32 percent of those 67 percent
are charged right if you were making the
case to be like look we need heavier
fines or we need more people or whatever
I get that but when she brings in stats
she doesn't make that case I I think I
think she just said the word statistic
because she wanted it to sound nice like
she's like oh that's a that's an
official sounding word so I'll say that
word but listen how she questions this
councilman and how he's confused about
some of this because she's asking
questions that don't make any sense here
listen you led the charge to reform DC's
crime laws is that correct
I cheered the committee that that
proposal came you led this charge yes
sir and uh these charges these changes
yeah are now law here in DC correct
um do you mean the revised criminal code
yes uh no those are not the law those
are not the
lawsuit code was rejected by excuse me
Mr chairman I've talked to Mr Allen Mr
Allen did you or did you not
decriminalize public urination in
Washington DC did you lead the charge to
do so no it the revised criminal code
left that as a criminal charge did you
lead the charge to decriminalize public
urination in Washington D.C no ma'am did
you ever vote in favor of
decriminalizing public urination in
Washington D.C the revised criminal code
did you ever support kept it as a
criminal offense did you did and you
support this criminal I voted for it
yeah you voted to keep it as a criminal
offense
we have records that show that you were
in favor oh of removing that criminal
offense oh my God and allowing public
urination no the is that something that
you intend to pursue in the future no
the legislation you're referring to that
came from a criminal code Reform
Commission changed public urination from
a criminal to a civil offense the
council then changed that to maintain it
is a criminal offense at the request of
the mayor
thank you I yelled
thank you I yield no you yield back you
[__] idiot the thing is Lauren bobert
really thought that she had something
there especially when she's like excuse
me the question was for him like okay
first off he's trying to clarify uh your
dumb ass question
and explain to you before you double and
then triple down on this idea that he in
fact voted uh you know for this or or
against his bill right so that public
urination could be decriminalized or
whatever the [__] she's trying to argue
there in terms of like the penalty
but Lauren bobert really does take this
role and be like oh you know what I've
got the power so you're good no don't
don't interrupt me right that was for
him right and it's this
it's an attempt at like this gotcha like
uh I'm in power you're not and here's
the problem it doesn't really matter
because she was proven wrong
uh multiple times he kept saying no no
that's not the law no no I didn't vote
for it no and she's like but did you no
I didn't how many times do I need to
tell you how many times you need to ask
the same question for me to tell you no
and for you to understand that is I see
people I just I finally look over at the
chat today uh really and saw somebody
say it reminds me of Dick and Jane when
he's trying to say statistics
and I I want to play it well I don't
know if we'll get dinged for it but yeah
it probably will
um I will I will say this though
you know I don't know if she's been
watching Law and Order or she was
watching Like A Few Good Men to try to
figure out how she was I see a question
I think in Law and Order you at least
there's that at least like either on
either side there's some level of
Competency where someone's trying to
make the case right
I feel like
it's a tactic it's like a It's A Few
Good Men tactic
and she's like that's what I need to
have I need to be the Tom Cruise of A
Few Good Men right and you know
I want the truth you can't handle the
truth did you order the code red you
goddamn right I did like that's the
moment she wants right here she wanted
to order public urination you God damn
right I did I want people to piss
anywhere they want what the [__] is
going on here so Lauren bobert made it
on the list of course she could be on
the list every [__] week but we ain't
got enough polls for this dumb dumbass
um let's move on to our um Alpha cook of
the week
Lindsey Graham licking lips Lindsey
Graham oh man these [__] were
almost crying last night on Fox News and
Lindsey Grandma's one of them look you
look at you look at him you look at Don
Jr they were both crying they had tears
in their eyes being like I can't believe
they would after my brother
I mean Lindsey Graham was pimping that
um that [__] campaign account
um oh yeah are you gonna play the clip
with the laughter in the in the heckling
no well I mean we can I'm just gonna
play this one here yeah now what was the
heckling were they heckling Lindsey
Graham yeah so they were in the studio I
don't know if they're in the same Studio
or in a difference no they have they're
in the live studio that Hannity's in oh
yeah yeah so there were people so yeah
so the they had to
because there were people that were able
to at least vocally Express his mic was
picking them up yeah so that you hear it
in part of it there's like a bunch of
commotion and then it cuts out right and
then there's there's one time on one of
these clips you also hear it from the
Lindsey Graham side but here's
here's Lindsay and I it looks like he's
been crying now I don't know if he's
crying because he has to go on here and
defend Donald Trump in a way that makes
him look like a [__] boot licker or
if he's really crying that the guy that
has all kinds of dirt on him is about to
be in I mean he's been a boot licker for
a long time now ever since then I mean
that tweet that he had
keeps coming up in all of these
situations indictments or charges or
investigations it's like you know I I
know which one you're talking we'll show
we'll show that one right but let's
let's see how close he is to see if the
audience thinks that he's actually gonna
cry here let's listen
how do you do it you take a well if you
got a pile of crap and you chop it up 34
times it's still a pile of crap it's
duplicious charging they're trying to
smear the guy they're trying to take
cases that nobody else would take and
resurrect them this is literally legal
voodoo
he made a statement there's another
Clipper he's like I don't know if legal
voodoo's a thing but this is legal
Voodoo right he doesn't know if it's a
thing because I don't know you know
what's funny is this this [__]
is a Jag lawyer did you know that yeah
yeah
it's a [__] Jag lawyer man
Hannity brings it up in this interview
and he goes you're a lawyer and he goes
oh I am a lawyer right and I'm like
you're not making a good case right for
why what you're saying so so you're a
Jag lawyer who's prosecuted all kinds of
[__] crimes Lindsey Graham and you
don't know if or if when or if there is
legal Voodoo that you're talking about
get the [__] out of here man you made
you made up [__] that's all
they are is made up [__] you
people just make [__] up it is [__]
ridiculous how much [__] you make up
they do this in that [__] Twitter
space room they make sure like Jenna
Ellis making [__] up about [__] the
election in the 2020 like you're making
[__] up [__] and then when someone when
someone's like you had to go before a
Colorado judge and admit that you lied
ten [__] times she's like Ah that's
not true yes it is right [__]
signatures on the goddamn page yeah
they're talking about it's not true
these people are [__] line sex and
garbage well they are are I mean
yesterday so yesterday I I don't know if
somebody I had to leave the space
because my my phone was glitching out
but I did have a moment where I was on
stage and Jenna Ellis had been talking
about election Integrity right and this
and that and blah blah and I was like
you know what I think it's pretty funny
right that Jenna Ellis is talking about
election Integrity when we know that she
admitted to lying about or she admitted
admitted to spreading falsehoods about
the 2020 election and then they're like
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa easy on the
person a personal attack it's not a
personal attack it's the [__] truth
man I'm also speaking of someone's
character if you're gonna talk about
election Integrity you know like the
hypocrisy of you saying we need to hold
up the uh the Integrity of the election
meanwhile she's also the same person
that spent 2020 the 2020 election
pushing the idea that there was a big
lie Donald Trump didn't actually lose uh
uh Rudy Giuliani didn't fart on her and
give her covid and you know that there
was a kraken that was going to be
released from Sydney Powell and none of
those things were true right let me
accept the fact that she got um coveted
from Rudy giuliani's fart but you know
it's one of those things where you hear
these people they're lawyers these are
lawyers which is crazy to think that
these people are able to practice law I
mean like Jenna Ellis is a traffic like
ticket lawyer so she's not really much
of anything right she was a nobody and
the reason that she's a somebody now is
because of her role in line in the 2020
election and pushing the big lie but all
of these people you would think that for
some for some
fraction of a second that they would say
you know what ah man I'm a lawyer and I
know that this is completely wrong and I
know that what I'm telling people is not
actually the rule of law and I'm just
pushing my own opinion because it's it's
something that that benefits my party or
right well under indictment the rich
thing is is when you push back on them a
little bit they get all pissed off oh
just like this pisses Lindsey Grandma
why hasn't he deleted this this is from
2016 May 3rd you know what it's because
he doesn't know how to use the Twitter
could be that could be he he tweeted
this and it still exists it's it's real
this is real I'm not making this [__] up
if we nominate Trump we will get
destroyed and we will deserve it
so 2016 Lindsey Graham before Donald
Trump was nominated 2016. we're coming
up on seven years and he was very he was
correct then he's wrong about legal
Voodoo whatever he thinks that is again
these are [__] attorneys for crying
out loud okay uh let's see oh well some
reason that tile went away I'm gonna
have to edit it where is that there it
is okay I got it I got it okay
um so we're gonna go to our dishonorable
mention another one that was crying
my daddy my daddy is gonna get gonna get
an indicated he's got an indicatement
coming from the Manhattan D.A
um it's Donald Trump Jr booger sugar
Junior as I referred to him
um you know it's not surprising that
this [__] box
would put out a video now he did a
couple of them yeah he said basically
the same thing in the videos yeah I said
one from his car yeah he did do one from
his car and I'll say this much
do I have that video on my computer now
oh he was making to you was he recording
let's just say I haven't I haven't
filmed it yet but the way that I'm
thinking about making this video is I
might be in the back seat of the car oh
I see well he's you know a Christian
Walker type video is what I'll probably
make is I'm in the back seat while he's
talking on his phone up and up in front
talking yeah here's here's the clip he
did on his uh his uh podcast show called
triggered he's really triggered in this
clip by the way so triggered I don't why
did he call his [__] show that I'm
triggered like that's it because I
probably if I had to imagine that he was
like man that was a good title on my
book and you know what I need people to
buy more of those books to fund a
certain habit yeah a certain habit I
like is his hair turning gray on his
beard or is that coke
uh you know that's a that's a question
that a lot of Scholars don't know the
answer to many of us are wondering that
very I mean I'm getting some gray hair
you know my birthday was yesterday and
what a great birthday present from Alvin
Bragg I want to thank him again for that
birthday I mean greatest birthday
present I've ever got to be quite honest
with you but you know I'm getting gray
hair but you know
I just think this guy does too much goat
for that gray in his beard not well if
you look at the photos that compare him
from 2016 like seven years like yeah I
get that people age and you know there's
a lot of stress in people's lives and
stuff like that but like the amount of
gray that he got in
that amount of time or even less than
that really like I mean the gray hairs
were all the way back in 2020 2021 so
really like you had a three four year
period five years of Max where he went
from uh Blackbeard to greybeard and it's
just like is this like pirates pirates
of rednecks I mean because you know he
really did try to take the whole redneck
thing he grew a beard yeah yeah he puts
on the flannel shirts now and he wears
those clean pressed jeans and the brand
new boots you know they're in the
massive jeans too they got little they
got they got a little thing in the back
yeah they got like the the gems on them
or whatever let's listen let's listen
dude
um Donald Trump on his podcast I'm
triggered I'm triggered let's listen I'm
gonna go uh make some phone calls I'm
gonna look into this further
um I'm gonna see you know what exactly
it means and you know talk to the team
uh maybe we'll have to do a special over
the weekend I just you know I don't have
much more to say other other than the
insanity of what it is the weak need
response from so many Republicans
especially those that you know have done
a really good job of paying influencers
to make them seem really Maga you know I
get it unfortunately that's the game and
that's what it is for them you know I
don't really care about these things
they care about what they're donors
ultimately tell them because that's
where they get their money that allows
them to continue and perpetuate their
careers that's why they hate Trump
because Trump doesn't really need them
it's why they've pulled
all the stops to go after Trump for six
years I know a little bit about it
myself because they did the same to me
for what's never going down for until I
don't know we say enough is enough again
until we become unafraid to speak out
they have spent probably trillions wait
putting you in your place wait wait
these people Donald Trump Jr and Donald
Trump are afraid to speak out that's all
you do you people don't shut your
[__] mouths are you kidding me I mean
I I've said this before it reminds me it
reminds me of the Netflix movie Death
2020 where Lisa Kudrow is like I'm gonna
go where she talks about her character
she's like look it's it's the liberal
media and the left that's trying to
silence me I talked about it in my book
or my number one bestseller book right I
talked about it on my podcast I talked
about it on Joe Rogan's podcast right I
talked about it in this Senate hearing
you're silencing me yeah I talked about
it in an interview with uh with Tucker
Carlson the idea that these people are
being silenced it could not be further
from the truth they have one of the
biggest platforms Twitter and Facebook
and Instagram and Rumble and I mean not
truth social well I mean even even
libtards like us take the their clips
and show them yeah like what are you
talking about I mean I don't want you to
I actually don't want you to shut up I
don't want yeah I actually frankly it
isn't your your worst interest to keep
talking like you're talking and to
continue to do this [__] I'm for it I go
in that space and I'm like I I pissed I
pissed off Tom uh Fenton and said Gorka
that one time I was like you go you guys
are the best yeah at recruiting do not
stop you are best at recruiting liberals
to our ideology and and our way of
thinking than there ever could be you
people are so [__] nuts and so out
often to [__] lot land that no one's
gonna believe a [__] thing you say
like not any of it any of that they're
starting to not believe anything you say
which keep talking keep saying crazy
[__] right like Carrie Lake style [__]
like as if Carrie lake is ever gonna
have a chance in hell of being elected
anything in Arizona ever again you crazy
[__] she has residence now at
Mar-A-Lago that's how much time she
spends they're hoping because here's the
thing she knows that she's not going to
be the governor she knows that her case
she lost her she can't be the senator
she won't be the [__] dog catcher
anywhere okay so that's why she really
looks at this as I I honestly believe
and I don't think it's uh she has a shot
but who knows I mean there's still a lot
of time till the 2024 election but I do
believe that she understands that she's
lost right like she she's not going to
be the governor she's not going to run
for the Senate but she does have a
better chance because here's the thing
she has a better chance of being a
potential VP nominee right a running
mate because at least they're running be
like oh yeah I was formally uh the
running mate for vice president which
you could say is you know maybe holds
better uh Merit on a on a resume than
you know a gubernatorial candidate or
you know somebody who was considering to
run for Senate but at least in this one
she doesn't have to have
her people in Arizona she's like I'll
spread the I'll spread the net wide out
to all of the [__] crazy people in
the U.S to better my chance at possibly
being elected and she knows that she
knows that she's not going to win any of
the challenges that she's made she's
already lost her cases I mean even the
one that was just based on clerical
error that they had to fix she already
lost that so that's that's actually a
good point and because I'm going to show
this Don Jr the one from now he says the
same thing here that he said on the
trigger another trigger clip right um
because he's triggered but he's
triggered in this clip this is just a
car video but I want to talk about that
finish with Carrie Lake here yeah so
basically yeah well she knows she's
going to lose these cases right yeah
yeah he's going to lose and and I think
when she does finally lose and there's
no there's no way for her to say we have
a court case anywhere because eventually
there's going to be this situation where
she has no court case it just it's not
going to be feasible for her to continue
to lie about court cases and that
they're winning and [__] because that's
what she keeps saying which she's doing
the absence she's losing these court
cases but here's the thing once she
doesn't have a court case anymore I
think that's probably a month or two
after that is when Donald Trump makes
her his running mate
um and I I think that's the case that's
what it'll be but let's let's go to
let's go to Don Junior you know what
kind of car he drives do you know what
this is I don't know I can't tell
I tried to look at this last night from
the head seats right to see what it is
like it's got
of course he's gonna tell what it is
metal like or a plastic is this a pickup
truck this might be like a Ford F-150
yeah it might it might even be like a
Silverado or something I mean I would
imagine I would imagine this guy drives
a pickup now he probably never yeah I
mean like I can tell you right now like
this is it is a it's a pickup truck I
can tell you right now on the headrest
there's metal on the back of the
headrest it looks like there's like a
tablet or a screen right because I know
his kids so I'm assuming that you know
it's for the kids
um but I can't tell you from just this
alone what he drives I'm sure I'm sure
there's a photo of him with his his SUV
somewhere and you would know exactly
right well this and again this might be
an SUV I can't tell if this window in
the back is a truck window at the bed
behind it or if it's if it's actually uh
an SUV so it's hard to tell I just just
wondering I'm just wondering how how
ordinary this guy is you know what I
mean like right how down to earth an
average male this guy is they wanna he's
put on the flannel grew the beard try to
look like he's just one of us you know
one of these one of these average am I a
common man right I'm Coleman oh yeah
okay and yeah I got it silver spoon uh
but let's let's watch this is hilarious
what he Compares this indictment to it's
[__] it's so funny just listen
so guys you still think uh
we have a
equal system of justice you don't think
it's a two-tiered system
it is a two-tiered system and the reason
why you're scared is because your tear
is no longer protecting you right you
[__] bonehead it's just like margin
Taylor green it was it's so convenient
for you guys to not have an issue with
the justice system until the point at
which you're held accountable right in
the justice system and then you say whoa
whoa this isn't fair guys former Prez my
daddy he shouldn't be he should not be
indicated right right why is my why is
my daddy be being indicated when we're
supposed to have white privilege where's
our White Privilege that you've been
talking about okay let's let's continue
it's great what he Compares it to though
yeah like he knows nothing about these
things and you can tell when he Compares
it
I guess you haven't been watching folks
I've been watching this is
political
weaponization of our government against
its citizens and against political
opposition and resistance like we've
never seen before this is okay so I did
not know and and maybe maybe this is
something that is news Donald Trump Jr
apparently thinks that Alvin Bragg is
running in the Republican primary
because that that is the only way that
Alvin Bragg could be
Prosecuting his political opponent
Alvin Bragg is not Donald Trump's
political opponent I didn't know Donald
Trump was running for Manhattan D.A and
I didn't know Alan Bragg is running for
the Republican nomination this is so
stupid like what are you talking about
you're it's it's to kill your political
opponents Alvin rag Donald Trump is not
his political opponent okay he's not not
gonna be Donald Trump only wishes Alvin
Bragg was his [__] political opponent
here let's keep going this is the kind
of stuff that would make Mao oh [__] oh
my God and other sociopaths blush and
it's oh yeah oh yeah he loves to bring
those names up a lot right he he really
he really thinks that a bunch of
genocidal Maniacs who were
authoritarians who ran countries and
killed their own people would blush
because Donald Trump got indicated on 34
business fraud charges you people are
[__] ridiculous absolutely [__] I
cannot wait I cannot wait until this son
of a [__] is tried with the is charged
with obstruction of official proceeding
and possible conspiracy to commit
sedition that that is the moment where
I'm like okay so what was worse you're
34 [__] business fraud charges or the
conspiracy to overthrow the United
States of America get the [__] out of
here you people are so [__]
ridiculous I mean I try to be extra Gabe
Sanchez I really try on a daily basis I
come here for two hours and I raise the
bar I raise the level and I say some
crazy ass [__] I'll admit it but I
cannot believe that Donald Trump Jr
thinks that we're going to believe that
[__] murderous authoritarians would
blush because Donald Trump's gotta go
self-surrender and and be really Feast
of his own recognance because he made
really stupid [__] criminal choices
in his business practice you [__]
boneheads get the [__] out I can't wait
to get in this space I hope Jenna Ellis
is there today I'll Rudy Giuliani [__] I
hope this cocksucker's there today let's
keep going it's happening right here in
America the America you know and love is
gone oh my God and it's why we need to
fight to bring her back
so here's what I think here's what I
think he's saying the America that is
loved and gone is the one that affords
the privilege to white males that's the
one he's talking that's what they mean
by make America great again they mean
make it right make it male I mean yeah
what they want is remember the good old
days where a white man could say and do
whatever he wanted he didn't commit a
crime and no one would ever come for him
yeah the good old days and it's like oh
okay that's uh that's really [__] up
way of thinking about that but that's
not how it should be
well I find it appropriate that um three
of the prosecutors that are coming after
Donald Trump and his [__] family are
not white males oh yeah
for his business Alan brags after his
criminal
um practices in his business and and
finally Willis down in Georgia is after
the election fraud he does not steal the
elect he does not like it right that is
and even even uh hold on I I just want
to confirm the judge who's overseen
because the judge who is overseeing the
arraignment is the same judge who was
overseeing the Trump organization case
right all right that's the straw that he
drew right right and I'm trying to
remember his his name is uh Juan yeah
I'll pull up the statement too from
Grandpa Poopypants this morning where he
is obviously he's gonna have a like this
judge is going to decide his release
conditions right yeah the judge that
he's talking about in this statement
um and we're gonna well you know what
let's just go to bonehead because we
have these three contestants and we know
who the [__] winner is we know the
winner is of course is Donald Trump
because he was indicated yesterday he
was indicated to the highest degrees of
indication that could be happening in in
the history of indication and it's the
most egregious indication that has ever
been wrought in our in our great country
the United States Trump
um
he's losing his mind though this morning
here's this uh the the statement he put
out on on fraud social about the judge
he said the judge assigned so stupid
assigned they draw straws dude yeah
that's just how it works man that's how
it works it's called random right and
and you randomly chose a judge that has
[__] has had to make decisions in
your criminal ass cases before because
you do so much criming stop criming
that'll help you [__] [__] uh the
judge assigned to my Witch Hunt case a
case that has never been charged before
hates me you're so [__] dumb the case
that has never been charged before as if
these charges don't exist inside the law
Alvin Brett can't charge you with crimes
that don't exist you [__] bonehead
these statutes have to exist for you to
break them for him to charge you you
[__] idiot right he goes on to say
his name is Juan Manuel uh march
marching is that is that how you say it
marchan uh was hand-picked by brag and
bronskiers not true and is the same
person who railroaded my 75 year old
former CFO Alan weisselberg my guess is
he's including Alan weiselberg in this
statement because he is terrified that
Alan weisselberg is going to flip our
hands flipped on him he goes on to say
to take a plea deal pled guilty even if
you are not 90 days fight Us in court 10
years life in jail what the [__] is he
yammering about look the reason why the
reason why Alan weiselberg took a
[__] plea deal is why almost anyone
takes a plea deal to lessen their
sentence
that's why they take a a plea of guilty
because the prosecutor gets a notch on
their belt sometimes sometimes they have
to turn on other co-conspirators
sometimes they do not they just have to
admit their guilt and they will give
them that deal
goes on to say he's strong-armed Allen
ooh he's strong-armed that judge strong
armed him with I don't know like a
proper procedure in in a courtroom which
a judge is not allowed to do and
treating my companies which didn't plead
viciously
appealing appall appealing what
I I you read it appealing
which sorry hold on I gotta go through
down at the very bottom viciously oh oh
he's healing yeah he's saying yeah yeah
but he can't appeal something no it
hasn't been done yet no
no and go ahead and appeal the 17
criminal counts of fraud against your
business and he's talking about the
viciously which is the 1.61 million
dollars that the judge [__] ordered
right that you pay for the crimes that
the business committed this is so dumb
and so ridiculous but this is what you
get when we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life right what we
get is there any footage uh has he made
a video this morning yet uh uh no well
there was a video that I shared but it
was from yesterday which was uh him
talking about the n-word oh yeah and
he's like you got it clear why does he
do that by the way well yeah I mean in
the video he was like just like I
predicted they're bringing it out it's
time to talk about the n-word nuclear
and it's like wait that's not the n-word
what the N word is nuclear that's what I
said now get on your knees and pray
that is exactly what his video said
right he said
uh
the big stuff we gotta talk about the
big stuff the n-word nuclear and it's
like again I don't know where you're
where you think that's the [__]
n-word like where did you come up with
with that as your definition or or your
understanding of what the n-word is but
it is funny who's like you gotta get
down on your knees and pray and it's
like yeah I bet a lot of your [__]
followers want to get on their knees and
pray to you well here is uh a a shot
from New York City outside the
courthouse and all the trumps supporters
showing up in support of Donald Trump
there or really the lack of those
supporters you might say yeah and uh I
mean again it's there is none there are
more reporters than there are you know
Trump protesters really the only Trump
protesters that are there are [__]
they're they're making fun of them it's
Walter yeah Walter has some great videos
yesterday he's rolling around on a on a
trump arrest Trump now flag or something
like that right uh he went down there
and just did an amazing job at trolling
in some people were like oh man there's
a bunch of fake news down here and he's
like I'm not fake news I'm Fox News
well here is uh here's a video of um I
wanna where the [__] is it yes this is
it this is it so here's a Sing-along
song we're gonna are we gonna get dinged
on this I don't know I don't know no I
know I think it will be all right okay
okay all right let's let's let's listen
to this uh this great video here
[Music]
and I just can't hide it
I'm about to go to jail and I don't like
it
I'm soaked indicted
and I just can't hide it
[Music]
I know I know I know I know I know
I am so screwed
I I feel like I feel like Jimmy Fallon's
team they were they've been waiting they
made that and they've been waiting on
that for like at least a few weeks
they're like whenever a boom we gotta do
it drop it drop it like it's hot
um so here um here now this is yesterday
before the indictment and um this might
this is a press conference before the
indictment with what they're claiming in
this clip are Trump's attorneys here so
let's take a listen in yesterday with uh
the press conference that was happening
with the apparently the volunteer
attorneys for Trump
everyone thank you for coming uh we are
Trump's Volunteer Legal defense team our
associate Rudy Giuliani
weather even one team of sunlight
touches the man who will collapse in a
piles they have a brief statement
um on behalf of the president we
understand that there has been claims
that he has been trying to encourage
people towards violence that is not true
he gave us this free statement if any of
his supporters
are out there you are the true Patriots
do not do not engage in violence wink
okay
and it goes on for almost two minutes
um where obviously these are not Trump
attorneys but you know what I actually
believe that Walter would be probably a
better attorney than the actual
attorneys that are oh yeah than Trump I
mean he you got I think I feel like you
you gotta know the uh the brain
of a trump supporter right like I've
spent a lot of time with the characters
that I've done and stuff but he's out
there on the streets doing this so he
he's privy to certain arguments that
people make that I've never heard right
and so he's like oh I bet you never
heard of this for a defense and it's
like
yeah you're right I've never heard it
that's that's ridiculous that sounds
like something a trump supporter would
say speaking of trump supporters last
night on Fox news they were just [__]
freaking out and can't hear his
um highlights from the absolute meltdown
on the indictment in Fox News I like
this clip so I'm gonna because it it
gives a lot of different uh Clips here
from Fox News let's let's listen if you
don't watch Fox News here are five
highlights from last night's complete
meltdown over the Trump indictment there
were times last night when I genuinely
thought people were going to cry I'm not
exaggerating if you had zero context you
would have thought somebody died give
the president some money to fight this
[__] looking a little emotional I
feel the same way my heart is broken I
had some tears in my eyes some of us
tried to spin the indictment into a good
thing watch Pete hegseth really
overestimate Donald Trump's cool Factor
if there's a mug shot of Donald Trump
it'll be in dorm rooms and on t-shirts
and it gets Dumber here's Greg Gutfeld
saying that now Donald Trump has street
cred he he is an OG right if they give
me I mean he is a badass if he's got a
mug shot I honestly can't wait for this
mug shot to come out because Fox hosts
are gonna have to pretend that he's the
handsomest man they've ever seen
Tucker brought Glenn Beck on to talk
about the indictment and Beck
immediately went off the rails the Bill
of Rights is gone by 2025. we are going
to be at War we'll have a currency
collapse and we will live in a virtual
police state honestly I just don't think
America is efficient enough to get that
much done in two years Denmark maybe but
not America to no one's surprise the Law
and Order crowd suddenly didn't like Law
and Order and according to them grand
juries are now Stalin stalinization of
the American Criminal Justice System the
type that we normally associate with the
Soviet Union it's like Stalin's purges
but while we all love to make fun of
these people there was a ton of
dangerous rhetoric last night it almost
feels like they're pushing the
population to react yeah basically it's
one party hunting another it is a war on
conservatism in Maga they want you to
strike out Donald Trump was indicted by
a jury if anything this shows that our
justice system is still willing to go
after the rich and Powerful Republicans
could have even used this indictment to
get rid of the Trump Albatross hanging
around their neck but instead they've
committed themselves to a guy with 34
counts against him people better be
careful and that's all I'll say about
that I'll see you on Friday for next
week's recap but in the meantime I do
hope you'll have some fun watching these
Hypocrites meltdown oh we have all kinds
of fun here on bonehead of the week
watching these boneheads melt down
here's another um here's another one
who's melting down again this is um I
want to show you this so this is Laura
Trump this is Harry love to pitch the
[__] gold man look at the Gold over
here man they they cannot have the
screen is pitching
should we pitch our own gold should we
get like um [__] them gold or something
well I think yeah I mean I mean I think
you know there's fool's gold right and I
think that maybe we play on that you
know right or maybe we just sell maybe
maybe we maybe we call it
um golden golden [__] gold gold [__] I'm
trying to think because then at least
you would get something out of it so
it's like a little poop little poop uh
shape gold oh really it's gold foil and
you unwrap it and there's chocolate side
so at least you're getting something
from it okay okay but this [__] they're
like just buying the gold and then
you're like well what who who owns the
gold like where's where's the money
going this is crazy Birch gold group
oh somebody says uh uh golden showers
gold and showers that ain't bad oh man
that ain't bad easier for something
here's here's and then we can do a new
uh commercial
um we got we got uh um Laura Trump here
with the Birch gold pitching the Birch
gold on the on the other side another
another fraud but here she's making uh
she's making a claim again that Alvin
Bragg is Donald Trump's political
opponent which is [__] weird but
let's listen the America that has stood
for nearly 250 years will never be the
same we can never go back because now
we've talked about it and said well what
if now it's it's going to happen Okay so
I'll agree with her that we will never
be the same again there will never be a
president walking around climbing like
this [__] thinking they can get
away with it yeah what what what don't
they understand about this like yeah
it's not going to be the same it's not
and the reason why is because there's
not going to be [__] who run
for president or become present or leave
as president and run around doing just
whatever crime they [__] want because
they think the law does not apply to
them that's probably not going to be a
thing because we've only had a few of
them right in modern history that have
done it there's only been a few that
were really not afraid to commit a lot
of crime either before during or after
their presidency and I want to I I wanna
I wanna assume safely assume I'm I'm
putting this in uh out there as
as something that could not be true but
there's a part of me that that sees any
political candidate that would run
and then they would say to themselves ah
should I do the same like even before
this happened even before he was being
investigated you know it really did I I
think there was a question a lot of
Republicans Minds were like um you know
I would want to want to run for this
office or want to run for president
let's say
and consider be like could I even could
I even hit that same level
right should I even try to do that right
like is that something where it's like I
should like because it's just something
where I look
and I say like I don't I mean look
anything is possible but I honestly
don't imagine somebody running for such
a high office like the presidency and
then being like Oh man
I was able to get more crimes or I was
able to go to court more times or I was
able to get uh convicted or or charged
or sued with all these things more times
than president Trump like that's a lot
to accomplish that's what I've been
saying about Rhonda Santos what is he
going to do stand on stage and go hey
you like this criminal I'm gonna cry
more than he crimes right like you love
him because he's a criminal and I'm
gonna do more of you know what you know
what I learned yesterday what's that
while all of this was going on yeah it
sounds like uh yeah that is right was
trying to uh hide the fact that he was
getting the Florida legislator to repeal
the law the he can run and be Governor
exactly
because he needs that yeah because he
doesn't want to give up his governorship
because that's his Almighty his Almighty
bully point but I mean he doesn't have
it anymore like he's he's he's he's over
after this term like he can't run again
right well he can't he can't run it
currently he can't run for president
officially and be Governor he can't do
that either so he's got a [__] or get
off the pot with your organs who wants
to eat it too right in the right
situation where it's like you got to
choose you're either going to be out
you're going to be telling everyone that
you're running or you're not right well
speaking of political opponents let's
see if you can catch who Laura Trump
thinks is Donald Trump's political
opponent here it's [__] weird you
have the weaponization of the justice
system very clearly very blatantly
against a political opponent
now that would mean if if Alvin Bragg is
weaponizing his justice system in the
Manhattan DA's office that would mean
that Donald Trump and Alvin Bragg are
political opponents they're not
political opponents I mean they're in
opposite parties I'll agree with that
and Donald Trump doesn't seem to like
Alvin Bragg that much he calls him he
basically in all intensive purposes he
calls him a Jew with a hard r i mean
that's what the George Soros talk is
right but he's not his political
opponent that is all [__] Alvin
Bragg is not running for president in
the Republican primary and Donald Trump
is not running for Manhattan D.A what
the [__] are you talking about they're
political opponents that is such
horseshit
and that is something that should never
happen in this country that is something
that happens in communist USSR like um I
don't know when people are like lock her
up lock her up lock her up and even
Donald Trump on stage in the debate
stage he said I would put you in jail to
Hillary Clinton to her [__] face you
mean like that Laura Trump get the [__]
out of here with this [__] man the
[__] you [__] ignorant pieces of
garbage I can't even hardly take it
anymore so yeah these people are dude
they're they're something else man I
mean again like they they want to
complain about this justice system now
when it's them on trial or them being
charged but anytime anyone else does
right like uh before you know Donald
Trump was able to save people on a
federal crime level because like oh hey
you did you did it you didn't you made a
little boo-boo on a federal level pardon
right I'm gonna I'm gonna pardon you I'm
gonna pardon you and now
because we've got a state level crime
you know he doesn't have the luxury
right nor would someone I mean you know
Joe Biden can't save Donald Trump from
these charges even if he wanted to
that's right I can't do [__] right I
can't do [__] [__] the same way
the same way that the oversight
committee a federal group cannot jump
into a state level investigation and try
to stop it from from from an indictment
ever happening right you got to
understand that that's just not how
things work right but for Republicans
the weaponization of the federal
government anytime the the Democrats do
something any time that is left of the
of the park
your mic cut out there
I don't know what happened
I don't know
I can't nope
um well go go ahead and try to fix it
I'm gonna go to Benny Johnson Benny
Johnson's another [__] asset that
shows up in these Twitter spaces oh
Benny shows up today too
um I'll give him what for my mind as
well but here's the tweet that Penny
sent out and I don't think he realizes
what kind of narrative that
that this is uh
just setting up on the T he says Donald
Trump was indicted before anyone on
Jeffrey Epstein's Client List let that
sink in also you could say
Donald Trump was the first
the first to be indicted on Jeffrey
Epstein's Client List what the [__] why
the [__] would you put this out in the
universe right can you hear me now yeah
okay cool yeah no no I mean like it
totally Benny Johnson says a lot of
stupid [__] did you see the one where he
said he's like well that just won Donald
Trump the black uh vote and it's like
what yeah I've seen that one um
dude I don't know where you think that
you yeah it's just it's just it's just
insane Benny Johnson is a [__] idiot
um he's an asshat I mean he was on he
was on these Twitter spaces the other
day talking about you know he really got
into it and was like oh man the Deep
State and the weaponization and this and
then blah blah I mean by the way Benny
Johnson is like Don Jr is like buddy
buddy uh they always they always chat
with each other yeah together probably I
don't know I'm assuming I'm not I don't
know that they sit at the same Nazi
table with like you know
it's it's
um
Benny Johnson is
is an idiot who could not give you any
political Insight right and I don't
claim to be an expert but I can tell you
Benny Johnson here with a tweet like
this
holy [__] this is great
now this must have came right after
because this this was 907 p.m that's my
time uh so it's it's
so it's yesterday yeah yeah yeah that's
yesterday but but the indictment
happened at like what 4 P.M my time
right but I'm saying this is after the
indictment oh yeah yeah yeah
this is everyone this is everyone who's
trying to push this idea that uh oh
guaranteed he got the vote he's a martyr
look at that you just brought him the
election you don't even know the charges
yet you dumb sons of [__] it's a martyr
for what so because he's a business
criminal this doesn't have to do with
January 6 or him being president that's
what they don't understand it's like you
can't indict a present this is political
this has nothing to do with him being
president right there's 34 counts of
business fraud yeah [__] boneheads so
Benny
Johnson tweets Trump just won the Black
vote what the f what on what [__]
parallel universe does Benny Johnson
not only think that this is true but how
does he come to this conclusion like I
can't even reverse engineer the
stupidity here
I don't understand I don't I don't
really know I don't get it because Trump
is criminally indicted and all black
people are are victims of the justice
system that somehow they're going to be
sympathetic to Trump is that what he's
saying I I I I honestly don't know like
Trump's indictments here and then Benny
Johnson's logic is like [__] man it's
out it's way out in left field or right
field I guess you could say but like you
look at this and you're like I don't
understand the connection if the
connection is because uh there's the
incarcerate the incarceration rate is
higher amongst the the black population
yes so that's a [__] and they're
sympathetic because now he's gonna be
he's gonna be indicted I guess but also
like there's no logic and it's such as
like vague post where it's like what
does that even mean I mean I get that
you're talking about you know him being
indicted or right I think I think it
just feels good for these [__] idiots
to be like oh yeah well now now he's
gonna get the Hispanic vote that's how
he's gonna win is with the black vote
you know that kind of [__] it's the same
is it again I said it earlier in the
show which is the same reason of them
trying to be like oh you know what
uh the FBI you know raided no it was a
uh actually it was an illegally executed
search warrant okay that's what it was
but when they're like oh no the FBI went
down to Mar-A-Lago after which Trump was
the one who informed us on August 8th uh
and and tried to play victim but all of
them said oh man you guys really [__]
woke up the bear now he's gonna go
through and trash it all this [__] the
red waves coming red tsunami yeah and
then you're like okay well
where was the turnout right so it feels
like you didn't win like you thought you
were gonna win right because your big
wins were the the governor and secretary
of state of Pennsylvania Michigan
Wisconsin and Arizona and you lost all
those races right every one of them and
the reason why is because you put
lunatics
Maga Trump back lunatics in those
[__] positions not only that you
[__] lost you lost the senate race in
Arizona with a lunatic you lost the the
[__] Pennsylvania one to a guy who
you claim can't even [__] cognitively
think or speak you lost you lost in
Georgia again with a [__] another
lunatic another Trump back lunatic you
[__] boneheads and in the state of
Michigan not only did they win the
[__] Governors the Secretary of
States they won the [__] the state
legislator back
and now they're actually able to to make
some common sense [__] legislation up
there in Michigan speaking of
legislators not having common sense
you know Alvin Bragg has had to put up
with the obstruction from Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan and James Q
Anon Comer
uh from the oversight and Judiciary
Committee they're threatening Alvin
Bragg they want him to give them his
their evident whatever the [__] they're
obstructing and my guess is that Grandpa
Poopypants and the Cheeto does q and
honor has been calling Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan and James q and
honor Comer to get them to do this which
if that is what they're doing if they're
doing this based on the orders of Donald
Trump this is [__] criminal
obstructions I did there was a uh there
was a tweet I saw last night and and the
conversation was around that which was
yeah Donald Trump was contacting people
on these committees to pressure them to
do this which that's obstruction that's
criminal obstruction well here's the
thing here's the letter from Alvin Bragg
uh this morning to uh Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan and the house chairman
of the Judiciary Committee is painful as
that is to say and James q and on Comer
who is the chairman again it pains me to
say of the oversight of our oversight
committee but what really pains me is he
notes them as honorable they're not I
mean Alvin Bragg I get that you're
trying to be nice here but they're not
honorable at all not even not even a
little bit of Honor in these [__]
scumbags um but he does say yesterday
the district attorney of New York County
filed charges with against Donald Trump
for violations of New York law here's
your official if if you out there aren't
believing that he's indicted if you
still are doubting it here's a letter
from the Manhattan D.A to the house uh
committee chairs that he is indicted uh
the charges filed yesterday were brought
by citizens of New York meaning the
grand jury during their civic duty as
members of the grand jury who found
probable cause which we talked about
earlier to accuse Mr drop of having
committee crimes in New York
uh down at the bottom here it says we
did not engage in a point-to-point
rebuttal of your letter because our
office is legally constrained in how it
publicly discusses pending criminal
proceedings he's trying to tell him hey
you know this [__] I can't say
certain things dummy I can't disclose
certain things dummy until we get to
court it'll damage my case and his case
um the breast Security offices are
across the country and and as well as
you know that secrecy is critical to
protecting the privacy of the target
meaning Trump in any criminal
investigation as well as the Integrity
of the independent Grand jury's
proceedings you stupid [__] listen if
Jim Jordan and James Q Anon Comer want
the evidence here just wait just wait
like the rest of us it'll be in court in
open court if Donald Trump doesn't take
a plea deal it'll be right out in open
court we will see all the evidence and
Donald Trump will have his day in court
he will be able to present a defend it's
to his criminal charges that have been
that he was indicated for and his
indicatement
in the state of New York will or will
not be brought with charges and
convicted by a jury of his peers just
like the rest of us because it is true
you [__] moglodytes if this can
happen to us it should be able to happen
to Donald Trump and he is he is your
bonehead of the week let's give him his
due
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
it was something else I didn't I didn't
honestly I did not know you know I
didn't know how
how that I knew Lauren bober was not
going to win but the fact of having
margin even though that is that is a
bone-headed [__] clip oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's beautiful yeah
Lauren you couldn't have done a better
job at looking like a bonehead right out
of me than that I think someone else
said it it was today or yesterday she
got pissed on yeah pissed on well it's
better to be it's better to be pissed
off than pissed on and she got pissed on
with that okay I want to give everyone
who loves bonehead out there a little
bit of news uh on Twitter
I think they're going to restrict who
votes on polls if Elon goes forward with
some of the new changes he's going to
make tomorrow if it's not an April
Fool's joke or no April 15th as they
have so yeah whatever next month there's
going to be changes over the next few
weeks so we're going to still try to put
polls up on Twitter but if you can't
vote on the poll then we're not going to
be able to pull you if that makes sense
yeah I'm not gonna say you need to go
buy a blue chick so you can vote in the
polls so here's what's going to happen
we always put the poll up on YouTube so
if you're not subscribed to YouTube and
you want to vote for bonehead of the
week in the future if Twitter [__]
kills this ability for us yeah then you
gotta come to YouTube and go to the
community tab you just go to our Channel
hit subscribe hit the Bell notification
because then you'll get notified when we
post the poll or you can come to the
page and go to just slide over to the
community tab it's at the very top uh of
the videos Community Tab and all the
posts are there we post other things
like when Gabe has a what was that we'll
post the link to that sometimes we'll
just I'll post means over there so you
guys can rob them and go spread them
around the internet like herpes you know
what whatever you want to do we we try
we're gonna try to engage more on that
Community tab but that's where the poll
is going to be if you see see it leave
Twitter and we're going to talk about
this the next couple Fridays as Elon
takes away this ability for you to vote
on Twitter because that's what he's
doing we'll be able to put up a poll
right if but if you don't have a blue
check you're not going to be able to
vote is what they're saying that's what
they're saying is the new whole thing
um so but anyways follow us on Twitter
if you can at Tony Michael's pod maybe
they won't change it maybe he'll back
away from this I think tomorrow he's
really [__] in some of the stupid [__]
he's doing but also another thing to
help us with another thing that helps
with download every single episode on
Apple Spotify and Google
um so there is that everyone uh stick
around we got a few announcements I want
to talk about a few more things you got
about 10 minutes left for this three
hour Friday episode again and so don't
stick around this has been bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
um
no native the week sorry we've had a few
audio issues today it happens
um sometimes it happens every once in a
while
um so there's a few more things I want
to show here and that I didn't get to
you
oh yeah
well
there's just all kinds of [__] big news
you sent me a video big news this is a
uh it's a um a montage of um yeah yeah
yeah
uh let's see I want to show the one
video I want to show is yesterday
um of the let's see this is the one this
is the one
um so representative Gloria Johnson was
taking some video at the capitol of
Tennessee yesterday uh the right Wingers
are trying to say trans people are
showing up and having an Insurrection
here here's what they're talking about
here it you you [__] decide what kind
of insurrection this is listen
[Applause]
that is
[Music]
hold it up
[Applause]
[Music]
don't forget
all right so that's just a little bit of
the video there from that was the same
type of stuff we heard on uh on January
6th right like uh we we heard them say
I'm gonna let it shine yeah or oh no
sorry they said hang Mike fence right
that was my yeah that's what it was yeah
it's kind of a little different there
isn't it a little bit different I mean
they also screamed out things like I am
a [__] animal you know like that one
woman that footage that came out uh
really goes to show you that's uh right
it's uh day and night there's a big
difference between people who actually
want to protest peacefully for their
rights and have an armed Insurrection
because there were people that had
firearms in other words poles Spears
yeah here's the other thing too then I
want to say is that I think it's funny
that they're calling this an
Insurrection because they're like oh the
thing
wasn't an Insurrection this is like you
know
people really
they see through your [__] you get
that right you understand that right I
want to show you one more video
um this young man showed up at the
protest as well he was one of the last
ones there yesterday uh someone posted a
picture online I think it might have
been Gloria Johnson was pushing a
picture of this young man online still
sitting on the bench after all the
protesters had left the camper yesterday
because the lawmakers left so there
really wasn't much reason for the
protesters to stay if the lawmakers
weren't there to hear them protesting
um and and I'll I'll tell you that this
this is how our country makes change
with these peaceful protests but this
the story of this young man here and I
don't know his background or anything
like that but this is the son of the
school Pastor in Tennessee and he was
there to ask Republicans to take action
on Common Sense gun laws let's listen to
what he had to say this is Tennessee
holler has this clip
yeah that's right
is the school Pastor there
I'm a teacher myself I was at school I'm
teaching New Jersey
um and I my phone was blowing up
people had texted me that there was a
shooting
and I was lucky that immediately I
called my mom and she knew at that point
that my dad was safe for everybody at
that point
the shooter had been killed
um
so this young man stayed yesterday
um even after they had they had left and
he was still still waiting to talk to
whatever lawmakers would hear him and we
can't we can't forget this right just
because Trump's indicted and we're all
excited about that we can't lay down
this fight
um to pass Common Sense gun safety in
this country as I mean it's the it's the
the least we can do right so um and and
I actually again I think it's um crucial
that we point out that these [__]
boneheads are calling this an
Insurrection when it clearly is not and
I'm going to leave you with one more
video that uh Gloria posted of the crown
here uh and it's another it's another
part of the Let It Shine video and then
and then we'll we'll head out for the
weekend so take it take a look at this
one
please
subscribers
yes thank you
everybody
[Applause]
so there you have it there's the uh
there's the Insurrection that is
happening in Tennessee where they're
singing Let It Shine to stop children
from being murdered in schools for
lawmakers to do something anything
absolutely anything to stop people with
weapons of war going into school and
murdering little children I mean yeah
it's you know we should follow what you
know uh Jamal Bowman is doing right we
should be calling these people out we
should be calling you know obviously you
can't be in the capital yourself to do
that every day but you know call your
representatives you should be calling
contacting protesting peacefully of
course but you should be standing up
because there is no you know the fact
I'll say this
you heard Thomas Massey in that video
with with Jamal Bowman say calm down
calm down but you have to remember that
kids are dying right we have 19 children
died in Uvalde and they haven't done
[__] they they passed a gun Reform Bill
that had some things in but wasn't
everything wasn't everything that we can
do right but the fact that Republicans
now
like Birch it being like well you know
criminal's gonna do what a criminal does
we can't really do anything about it
that's [__] we can pass legislation
we can have tougher restrictions on guns
we can assault weapon bans you don't
need an AR-15 to go hunt a deer you know
you don't have to you don't need an
AR-15 to go hunt some some sport right
it's not it's not acceptable it's
completely preventable we have the
ability
to hold our Representatives our
congressmen our Senators all accountable
for the apathy that they have towards
children dying because they know they
can do something they choose not to do
something and that's the difference and
that is something that we need to call
them out on and we can't take our eye
off the ball and we won't hear on the
Tony Michaels podcast we will stay on it
we will stay on them and we will not let
up every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch don't
forget to subscribe here on YouTube
while you're here download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google this
weekend go check out our patreon Pages
go to what was that show.com or go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and while
you're over there check out my patreon
page I want to thank you for getting me
over 200 holy [__] you guys are you guys
are on it I'm working do my goal the
250. so thank you very much to all the
people who've joined Gabe's patreon and
mine and I know Gabe does his thing on
the weekend I'll do mine so um be
watching for ask ask me anything that's
probably going to be this afternoon or
this evening I'll do an ask me anything
on patreon so go to page john.com D Tony
Michaels check out what they ask me
anything is over there and also while
you're on there and check out Gabe's
page at patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or
what was that show.com follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels and follow
us on the up bar go ahead and go to
upwire.com subscribe to the up wires
YouTube channel and if you got an Amazon
Prime account please please please I ask
you to to tie it to your Twitch account
just just link those two and you get one
free subscription to Twitch with your
Amazon Prime account and you can give
that to us and we get a few dollars of
Amazon's money so if you want to give us
a few dollars of Amazon's money do that
and I noticed a few people did that
today so thank you thank you very much
have a great weekend be safe don't drink
a whole bottle of Jaeger I would advise
against it after this week I I would not
do that just have a few shots just a few
and a safe weekend everyone
we'll see you on Monday same time same
place Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon